Three,
two one.
Bam.
We live,
we got up early as a motherfucker,
ladies and gentlemen.
Not really.
It's 10:00 AM.
What did we do one at like 4:00 AM
before we did want at 5:00 AM for it.
Was it for,
it was a a is a England card,
right?
Was it something [inaudible] or something?
Congo and might've been,
it might've been trying to get China
like what time is in Africa right now?
Is it yesterday?
I think it's ahead.
Stay man.
Just,
I forgot he knocked out Whitaker.
We're looking at Wonderboy
stop and Whitaker.
That's,
yeah,
that's,
that's 70 yeah,
but that was,
Whitaker was diminished man.
Getting down to one 70 was
a fucking battle for him.
Do you look at Wonderboy
w what he's accomplished?
It's so impressive.
All the indicators would point that
Wonderboy should win this fight,
but I don't,
I'm on the fence,
man.
Well,
I think till really is a bad,
bad man.
There's no question about it.
But he did come up real
short on the way in,
which really bums me out.
Now I had heard that his
pregnant girlfriend is in.
This is what everyone's saying is in
the hospital and that she's had some
serious issues and he's been going back
and forth to the hospital and he hasn't
just didn't have a
chance to cut the weight.
Right.
A lot of people claim you know that.
That's exactly what the,
what the issue was.
I don't know that drama is never good.
Especially your first main card,
main event in your
hometown against Wonderboy.
There's enough pressure as it is.
Well the cowboy five was
a big pressure fight,
but he rose to the occasion.
Was it?
Cause we didn't know who he was really
haven't is this opportunity for sure,
but you're fighting a smaller guy.
Skins cowboy,
you know,
so he goes forward and does work.
Now it's like man,
I mean there's been guys who
have blown up before but the,
the hype on till and
I'm all up on his dick.
But you know,
there's a ton of hype on it.
If you went into this one,
it's off to the races.
It is,
but he's fucking four and a
half pounds over championship.
Wait,
that is a lot.
That's not a little,
that's a lot.
It's such an advantage to fighters to
have missed weight are undefeated this
year.
When they feel fight,
they're undefeated.
Yeah,
it's a big advantage.
I think that was one cheating if
you do it on purpose for sure.
I think what's interesting
with Wonderboy dead,
he said you've got to weigh
one 88 the next day type move.
Big Boy.
Yeah.
It kills a really big boy.
Very,
very smart.
Like whatever advantage that he got from
not cutting that extra three pounds,
you know,
and now he's a three and a half pounds.
Now he's um,
you know,
lost a little bit of it.
I guess if you're Wonderboy though,
you want to drag this into later rounds,
you know,
he's gonna come out aggressive,
he said some drama,
cutting weight and he had this cut
more weight to maintain it the day,
the day of.
So yeah,
it's all fascinating,
man.
So fascinating.
We're going to find out a lot.
The other thing is too,
the styles,
like what Wonderboy does
is a kicking distance.
Like if you watch like the
exchanges that he's at,
he moves real good at the waist,
like a snake,
like back and forth.
But he wants to keep you not
even at Moitai taking distance.
He keeps you at karate kick distance,
far sideways at very
far more self to reach.
Dan's got to close that gap and closing
that gap is when Wonderboy is the most
dangerous.
And if you see some of
his training footage,
he seems to be concentrating on
blitzing in and lent and countering and
sidestepping and countering.
Yeah,
we can hear the door.
Yeah.
If you look at Wonderboy is history.
Whenever he fights aggressive dudes,
they get fucked up.
Yeah.
That's like he's still that Scott
wants and that's what till wants to do.
Yeah.
That's very interesting.
I'm telling him that if nothing in the
slight would surprise me unless Dan until
just goes out there and
just murdered sexism.
Just no respect merge.
And that's the only thing
that would surprise me.
But if till does win strap a fucking
rocket ship that boys back cause in other
Bisping's retired UK,
neat.
The face.
That's him that he's the fucking guy,
man.
Even if he loses,
he could still be that he's 25 years old.
Yeah,
but not to that extent.
You know like you beat Wonderboy
and you knock out Wonderboy.
It's fucking [inaudible] man.
He's a super talented striker though.
What he did to cowboy,
it wasn't just impressive.
It was like complete domination to
moralize just controlled the range.
He controlled every single
aspect of the exchange is cowboy.
Got like one good knee
off at one point in time,
but that was in one good
right hand to the body.
I rewatched the fight the other day
just to kind of get amped up about
oppressive.
Oh my.
He obliterated them.
That's the thing too about till I think
it's so much hype is a lot of guys like
Colby Covington is amazing,
talented fighter.
There's a lot of guys talk a lot of stuff.
I'm like,
all right,
it's more of an act.
They're super talented.
When Darren till talks,
my God,
it's almost that Conor McGregor effect.
I'm like,
I bought this full,
actually believes it.
He believes it and he was ridiculous
skills and it's going to go a long ways.
It chipra your tank there.
There's me know Jujitsu in this.
Eddie,
no digits.
All,
I'll ain't goes to the ground.
We're all I know about Darren till his,
his fight with Serone.
That's it.
This card.
Uh,
you know,
it's,
um,
it's going to be interesting.
I don't really know who we're going to
have Gunnar Nelson on the card though.
He's going to announce it on the car.
No,
he got hurt.
But you don't have Gunnar Nelson.
Neil Magna,
which was a fun,
fun.
It's a great fight.
They were going to do Gunnar Nelson until,
but for whatever reason they
decided to go with Wonderboy.
Jason Knight,
I know,
I know about him.
Did he already fight on the daughters
on the main card and he's on the main
card.
Beautiful.
Who is,
he's a tough fight.
Um,
um,
like,
uh,
here's a tough fight.
Very tough fight.
Oh,
Connie?
Yeah,
he's a monster.
Connie.
Yeah.
The Japanese guy.
No,
no.
And he's,
well,
he lives in Finland,
but uh,
what is his background?
He's a
Dan.
He's a really good wrestler
who also has wild ass strikes.
Mouth find super tough fight for your boy.
Yeah.
Lila Magni who's Neil and magnified
now for wonder boy though there's not,
there's not a ton of upside.
I don't know why he took it to be honest.
Why?
It's a good matchup for him,
but yeah,
it's you're,
you're in dangerous territory,
right?
You're fighting the number nine guy.
You ranked number one,
he missed his weight.
He's huge.
Like there's just,
I feel like all the pressure's
off Wonderboy right now,
especially after he missed and weight.
But I just,
if you're Wonderboy and even if you
starch till they're not giving you a title
shot until Woodley loses that strap.
Wonderboy is not fighting for a
title 14 two and one for wonder.
Boy.
You got to remember the only loss
those to Tyron Woodley and then two,
I'm Matt Brown.
Those two fights and
one draw with Woodley.
Crazy.
That's why couldn't if I would be again,
they fought.
Well that's the,
that's what he's asking.
First of all,
he's saying,
why don't I get a shot
at the interim title?
How are you giving the interim title
to Colby Covington who only beat Damien
Maia,
who's 40 years old,
who's was clearly past his prime.
How is,
how is that good enough to get
him a shot at the interim title?
And I talked a lot of shit.
That's it.
Yeah,
there you go basically yet.
But it goes along way the same time.
Yeah.
It goes a long way this day and age,
but at the same time with Rda,
you know they're not doing Colby
and he favors send them down to,
oh no,
I'm sorry.
It's in Chicago.
Chicago to fight RDA,
which is,
if you look at Colby style,
it's probably the worst matchup for him.
He's a heavy underdog,
so I'm,
I'm,
I'm hoping,
not hoping.
I think what their plan would be,
Rda wins that fights Woodley,
which is tough matchup for Woodley
and the Rda were able to beat Woodley.
Then you have Wonderboy slip in there
or Colby wins and then you got mad shit
talking with him and Woodley
and it gets very interesting.
Get super intellect that fight going to
fire me and Tyron a Colby has done or
dog in every one of those fights.
Yes.
But Rda Woodley,
you got a barn,
burn your hands.
That's a great matchup.
Yeah.
Rda.
Woodley's very interesting
cause cause as much as as they,
you know,
I love woodland.
I think his style is ridiculous.
He's gonna be tough to beat.
You know,
I think they want some bit
of turnover in their ugly.
That's what they want.
Some turnover.
What does RDA going to do with
two Woodley and then he can't,
he's not going to ever take him down.
No.
He's the only thing he's got striking
his striking and his movements.
Good.
And then if it does go to the,
to the ground and his kicks,
that's a tough one to beat for anybody.
Yeah.
Even as striking,
even RDA striking Woodley has,
I'll put you to sleep instantly.
Striking.
What has more power?
Rda has better fundamentals,
I would say as far as
putting it more type,
run it together.
Kids feed the power and the explosives,
Goddamn nightmare.
It's still the favorite in the fight.
It's not going to the ground
and what he wants it to.
Woodley just got through shoulder surgery.
He just got his Labor and repaired,
which is not the worst shoulder
surgery and he does that mean exactly.
Stapled the Labor on labor.
Now the Labor,
um,
uh,
he had some sort of a tear in it that it,
that fucked up in the Damien
Maia fight like insulin.
They stitch it back together again,
but he's gone through crazy PRP
and all kinds of other shit now.
He put up a video of him hitting mitts
and it's only been about three months
since the surgery and he's hitting me.
It's hard.
I don't know if that's
an old video though.
He's sneaky.
You know,
he put up this video.
He's a free ham doe.
He might,
he might be doing,
you know,
who definitely got some injections.
He was talking about all the different
things that he's going to do for as far
as their,
he came on the podcast just a few weeks
after shoulder surgery and he was moving
around normal and moving
his hands around normal.
But it really depends
entirely on how bad this is.
The big one is the bicep tendon.
When the bicep tendon gets torn
off the muscle off the bone,
and then they have to put it back in,
stapled down everywhere.
And then they have to,
it does work right now.
Now does not for pitchers.
If you're a pitcher
and that shit go south,
you're digging,
he done.
But for a fighter,
no problem.
It doesn't seem to be
a problem for fighters.
But I bet Woodley.
So you got RDA,
Colby.
So the obviously the winter that
will fight Woodley end of the year.
Will it be back in the year?
No doubt.
Yeah.
It could very well be on
the December 31st card.
You know,
that's a big one.
Huge Guide.
Uh,
you know,
I mean I think they were trying to talk
about him being on the August card in
la,
but that's not going to happen soon.
Yeah,
that's a damn good card right now.
Right?
La is who do they,
isn't it?
Whose are,
they were willing for
GSP nae and I'll say,
that's not happening.
So what do you,
who do you have now in la?
Let's see.
Let's pull that up.
Did they put,
do they find a opponent for Xy beat?
This is going to be at staples.
Yeah.
Well they want to do cyborg versus
Nunez not happening in a suspended,
is she?
Yeah.
What's your hurt?
Uh,
her hands from whooping
that ass whooping that ass.
Damn.
Oh yeah.
Tj and Cody.
Ooh,
okay.
Yeah.
Oh,
a very cards.
Not,
no.
It's a little bit of
Struggle Street right now.
Not nearly as good.
August 4th car car's not nearly
as good as it was going to be.
No,
it was going to be a barn burner,
but in Congress.
Santa.
Yeah.
So far this card is a not well,
that's a lot of time.
They have some time though.
It does.
We're only in May and then there's
some great fights coming up.
Okay.
Robert Whitaker.
You well Romero son.
Ooh.
Chicago is one of the best cards ever.
Joe's Colby Covington.
Holly Holm.
Megan Anderson.
Hey,
let this sink in.
You've got cm punk first.
That Jack,
I forget his name.
Jackson over Overeem.
Curtis blaze.
Clearly Kadesia Esparza.
That's so disgusting.
And then on the undercard you got Rashad
Evans and my boy Joey Benevidez Pedis.
Cm punk said take a seat y'all.
That is so crazy Mike Jackson.
That is,
that is so crazy to me.
Oh,
in one verse.
Owen one.
Does that piss you off a no,
cause I get it cause I'm,
I'm not a fight.
If I was a fighter I'd be furious.
But now out of the game
and in the entertainment,
I get what you're doing.
Sounds a wolf tickets there.
I see.
I get what you're doing.
It's just the worst fight
of all time in UFC history.
Skill wise,
spice.
These good.
He's about to fight now.
Eric Spicy.
When do you guys know about him?
I don't know anything about them.
No.
I mean I've probably seen him fight
his black belt in Jujitsu is really the
favorite.
He's really good.
He's a weird body.
Um,
where's he from?
Jane somewhere on the east coast,
but when he's in La he
comes through my school.
Merck's everybody.
Really?
Yeah.
Does that,
does that cm punk
Jackson stuff bother you?
Joe?
Are you used to?
It now bothers me.
I don't like it.
I don't mind him fighting.
I think it's great that he's fighting
it and then you'll see that he's testing
himself in the UFC.
Even if they wanted to do in the UFC,
having him on the f you know
the prelims put him on fs one,
you know,
make it,
make it a um,
a fight pass thing.
I think his contract won't allow that.
I think if has guns or pay per view,
I would assume if you're seeing
punky have that big of a draw.
Maybe he was,
is he still be?
Think how many people are going to buy
that paper view to watch him fight?
I don't know.
That first one,
that first one,
he got his ass whipped so bad.
How um,
is the WWE like raging or is it,
that's why it's huge.
People are actually
going so just like that,
that raw and the raw sewage,
which Fox has now,
which in a lot of people I don't think
they realize Fox side to go with the WWE
instead of the UFC.
They turned down the EOC
and went with Doug Dob,
and now they have the raw sewage,
which gets like three something
million viewers every time they era.
It's a built in audience.
That's crazy.
I always bet on dudes were Harry backs.
Yeah,
their testosterone's usually way higher
than everyone else's and he's going
bald.
So we're two for two.
He's got some fucking gorilla back.
Look at that shit.
That's some werewolf type shit,
but not hairy legs,
which is weird.
Yeah,
very strange.
There's not weird,
that's some weird hair placement.
Unless you say as a Bush trying
to slip out of Lego blocks.
Let's get his legs.
I'll shave down.
He's got a weird body though,
right?
Yeah,
right.
It's a,
it's interesting.
He's a kid.
He's a character.
If it goes to the ground,
homeboys in trouble,
good jab.
He's got a good jab.
We'll get that pop,
pop,
you know,
good range.
Oh,
[inaudible]
damps too.
Or just popped it.
Where's Stuart from yet?
A white flag.
It looked like a red cross
flag as country Dune.
Fulcan England though.
Yeah.
The what?
Come on Scau slide.
I'm sorry,
I forgot.
That's right.
It was a Braveheart.
I forgot.
Fucking brave heart.
Haven't seen Braveheart and 10 years guys.
Totally different country.
God Damn it.
Shit.
Okay.
It's still United Kingdom that it's true.
Good point.
Yeah.
We were talking before the podcast
about how good [inaudible] a scouse
Liverpool access,
so it's fucking amazing.
So good.
He's so talented.
Yours was good too.
The other night become so,
yeah,
you didn't till it's fucking good.
It was good.
That was high.
Yeah.
That's channeling super legit though.
I've done everything I can to prepare,
dump,
dump.
A lot of pressure on the kid.
Yeah.
Well it's crazy.
If this is all going on,
as we heard that while his girlfriend is
pregnant and in the hospital and she's
having issues with the baby,
I can't imagine three down.
We've been through pregnancies
but was tearing to take them down.
Oh,
he just wanting a healthy baby.
That's the last thing I deal with.
Fight Week.
Exactly goes,
Ooh,
maybe not.
Maybe not do it the same
baby mama or a different one.
We probably don't.
I have zero idea.
Did you sync up?
Did you,
do people know where we're at now?
Do we still have that?
Not necessarily.
Do we have a uh,
uh,
a lot number on the screen and Jamie,
Jamie do hooks it up on the screen
now people are watching no type move.
Jamie fucking balls.
Jamie's,
it's vibrant today cause it's
game seven of the calves.
He's all nervous.
I look at him,
he's got double C's on double C's,
whatever it takes.
He's got to catch pray this morning,
Jamie for Lebron James help.
He burnt some incense and shit.
I saw that three pointer that he did.
He hit like,
I dunno,
game six or something.
The game later,
they actually have something
interesting going on.
Never concussion protocol that's getting
one of their players out so I could,
a guy got hit in the head during the
game and he can't play until it goes
through like five to 10.
Love.
Yes.
He's missing the game because he's the
fucking basket for game seven t o cause
Ucla Guy.
But God man,
the fuck up.
This is from a fight him.
It's the league.
It's,
there's rules in shooting seven.
It's not him.
It's the rules.
They do that for basketball.
Like some CTE in basketball.
Sure.
Who it was called.
Players that have had some problems
really ramp it like the NFL obviously,
but they get in trouble and they don't
want to be liable just like the NFL.
They get.
Makes Sense.
Crazy though.
Huh?
They're the last people you'd think that
would be putting people on the bench.
No,
I know.
So she came seven ESPN deal.
Like when does that start?
I don't know.
So you have C's gonna be on ESPN and yeah,
no more fox.
No more done.
No,
it finishes the end of this year and
it was on the coast to be Fox and ESPN.
We're going to split it,
right?
Yeah.
And then Fox didn't want
to pay like the premium by,
I think it's better,
I think.
I think it was a home run for the UFC man.
Delanda ESPN.
It's,
you know,
it's as serious as it gets
as far as major sports.
It's on one network when it,
and also with ESPN,
two of ESPN plus,
which we'll get some fight
nights and have regular ESPN,
ESPN two with Fox.
Not that they didn't do a great job,
but it was on Fxx fs to like fuck,
where is it,
where is it?
And announce UFC fight pass and out to go.
I think ESPN can learn from the mistakes
from Fox and just make it that much
better.
I think you're right about that because
there's been some times that I thought I
had my DVR set but then I get home and
it was on fs one I'm like mother fucker
or sometimes be like my bed or it's,
it's like my bat NASCAR's playing so go
to FX x times six well fuck man wears
that hat or a baseball game goes
long and you've got to go to fs two.
Yes,
I've got to find it.
That's 672 my my only concern on ESPN
because ESPN fc has the NFL has MBA.
How much,
how much focus do you even put on the UFC?
You know,
like we don't want to be the side chick.
Right,
because they're made to the NBA.
Nfl.
That's that.
That's their baby.
Are we the is the UFC
can be the side chick.
You know.
Good point.
Don't want,
but they'd been putting on
some good boxing matches there.
The llama Chenko Genco
contracted Luma Chanko.
Yeah,
they had,
they had another really
good fight on recently.
Check on my podcast coming up.
Ooh.
Yeah,
yeah.
Side for that.
I don't know how to say English is,
but we'll figure it out.
Yeah,
I'm a,
they contacted me too.
Yeah.
I think I'm going to have mine as well.
Might as well.
I've got questions.
I got a Lotta [inaudible] first
pull the trigger from
SPN
learned from my mistakes.
Get a translator.
It's sometimes it's like you think it'd
be a good idea to have somebody out,
but if you had them on like,
Ooh,
how long could you talk to them?
I know it'd be for the
showtime below the TV show,
so it's only six minutes segment.
Yeah.
When you've had a,
you've had cyborg gone but you've had
around with her boyfriend or boyfriend
translates.
Well,
no,
her English is pretty good,
but if there's ever issues,
so like takeover,
you know,
like she'll explain it
and then it's a little,
I'm a little like,
I don't know what you're talking about.
Right.
And then told her to take over,
but it works great.
Yeah,
it's hard.
You know when,
when I had a year,
well Ron,
it was the best because Joey was
translating for [inaudible] and so,
you know better than Joe.
It was,
dre was great.
So fucking hard gig though.
Translate and translate nightmare.
I can't shut up.
Joined do it for all the fun.
I mean,
Eddie,
you speak Spanish,
you know how hard it is.
I barely speak Spanish.
You speak enough like to talk to people.
We keep it light.
Yeah.
Soon as we get deep,
I'm lost Iranian start there.
They start real flowing fast.
And my grandma,
when she started,
you know,
I was the first of the grandkids
to lose Spanish and uh,
felt really shameful because of that.
But man,
it was,
it was rare.
It was really embarrassing hanging out
with my grandmother and she's going off
and I'm like,
I don't know what she's saying.
I got look it over to my aunts.
I'm like,
what did she just say?
Very embarrassed.
It's tough when you have a translator
because you don't get in that flow.
Like,
you know when a pot there's,
there's a flow and you're
like kind of connecting,
going back and forth where
if there's a translator,
just the chemistry's not there.
Right.
You don't have that fun kind of flow.
No,
but the one thing that is good though,
I,
what I find is that it allows you more
time to think about what you're going to
say,
oh,
we heard them.
Damn Stewart's 10 off.
Ooh,
spicy coming back.
But,
but sometimes when I have too much
time to think about the question,
I'm not,
you know,
I don't,
it's not as fun.
It's not as good sometimes organic.
Then I feel like,
uh,
like I worked for ESPN or something,
like I know exactly what you're talking
about and I don't want to be that.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Right.
That's the hard part of like having these
conversations with people is to keep
it,
um,
conversations and not turning them
into some corny ass fucking interview.
The worst,
there's nothing worse,
but sometimes you have to do that if you,
if you can't,
like sometimes I feel myself was still,
she was so shit.
I got hurt.
Oh,
that hurt.
that's it.
Stuart was an underdog to in this
damn hit him with some bombs.
England coming in.
Strung.
Yeah,
man.
I've watched those interviews are
standard interviews now where you know,
there's no connection between the person
talking and the other person answering
the questions and there so gross.
You know what?
I've done this conversation
with a Ken Jong.
Yeah.
Doctor Ken,
who's amazing,
might be the nicest guy in the world.
He's a sweetheart,
but he doesn't do a lot of it.
He's like,
podcasts,
really?
I'm like,
dude,
I'm having a public set up Joe
or something like the pockets is,
it's as big as it gets,
man.
He's like,
yeah,
Mike and I,
the example,
I gave him money.
He will say,
you went on tonight show and
you do a four minute segment.
You're going to have to,
you literally promoting whatever movie
or the stand up your special coming out,
but that's all you're doing is promoting
and trying to get people to buy that.
That's not,
that's not real,
man.
That's not the real,
you are like me and
we're talking like this.
If we filmed this,
people can be a fan of you
then buy whatever you can
be into or whenever you're
pitching.
It's a much better way to go.
There's no time limit,
no restrictions.
It's crazy that you never get it.
There's no other place for that.
Like even Howard stern would
do interviews with people.
He would get people to say a lot of shit.
He had a agenda.
Yeah,
he had an agenda.
Howard stern had an agenda typically.
Yeah.
Dirt out.
None of your fucking,
yeah.
That was an agenda.
The agenda.
He wouldn't,
he wasn't just having a
conversation with you.
He calls himself the dentist.
Okay,
got it.
Did he fuck people's teeth?
Does he have nice to see a dentist.
We'll hope he has bad teeth.
He knocks,
he pulls people's teeth out.
It's hard with his fist for sure.
Um,
it's a terrible name.
Yeah.
Well it's already been
taken to Josh neer Yammer,
mom Bro.
Old School.
That's a great name.
Do the,
knocked his teeth out.
What's a guy like Josh neer in my opinion.
He's a guy that is hardcore fan.
You know who Josh neer is and Josh
neer has been around a long time.
Fans don't know him though,
so that goes dead.
So cool.
Still.
That's like calling
yourself hands of stone.
If you're a boxer,
lay the fuck off.
That's Roberto Duran.
Yeah,
the fuck up.
I'm not saying that Josh is in
the same breath is Roberto Duran,
but still as a fan.
A fan
for a long time.
Yeah.
That's his nickname.
Someone had the hands of stone though.
Sounds Lineker John Lineker what about,
what about a harmonic or or Sam Stout?
One of them he could call.
So did a homeboy in strike was the
Kim over the UFC when he had that.
They almost had like the double knockout.
He hit a homeboy with a body
shot and they got knocked out.
Oh,
what's his name?
Scott Smith.
Hands the stones.
Right.
Had to steal,
steal,
steal.
There's a lot of that.
Yeah,
there's a lot of that going around.
You know,
some people just go hard,
but those fucking made up nicknames
and make them up for themselves and you
can't do that man.
You can't give yourself a nickname.
You just can't do that.
That's doesn't work that like you imagine
if a kid you went to neighborhood and
just give yourself a nickname.
He kicked the fuck out of here.
We're calling you.
Nah Man,
I'm,
I'm the dark night.
No you're not.
Well that's what I like about Brazilians.
Like they all have like silly
nicknames like shoe face.
Either our tree stump.
Yeah.
Fun Nickname.
Hell yeah.
It's calling you.
Like,
if you're,
if it's 2018 and you just starting
out and you call yourself to pit bull,
fuck off,
get the fuck out of here are
some that are off limits.
Is that the most common one?
It might be.
That might be on people.
Super.
There's about seven pit
bulls and Bella tour.
There's three in the UFC at
least when his girls too,
because look,
there are other cool dogs.
Isn't Jack Russell?
That's the coolest one.
Those are these
hunters.
Have you ever seen that Netflix
documentary where they use Jack Russell
terrorist to get rats?
There you go.
Yo.
It's crazy.
I feel like you want to
watch them a an hour.
No,
no,
no.
The,
the,
the doc.
The all on how fucked up rats
are and how many have got you.
You ever see that dude?
It will free.
You Use Jack Russells to go after raps.
Yeah.
Jack Russells are so aggressive.
Little terriers.
Um,
it's one of the reasons why they're
so aggressive is because they're,
they're constantly chasing
after these fucking rats.
When they get them,
they tear these rats apart.
Man.
I look at that damn dude.
Those are some Bush league dogs.
That's a,
that's a mix.
The Jamie that this is
from the movies are,
but these are some of them.
These are all part Jack Russell
terriers in in particular.
One of the reasons why they're
so small and so aggressive,
they would go into
holes and go after rats.
Dude,
look at the blood on the back.
Where the fuck are they?
So Michael Vick video dark place.
Oh,
but this documentary will
freak you the fuck out.
There's more rats than there
are people in New York City.
30 it's 30 million or 60
million rats or some shit.
[inaudible] they have like all sorts of
diseases that everything that can kill
you,
they have all kinds of deadly shit.
You just don't get it because most
people don't get bit by rats and they're
smart.
But we need rats though.
Right?
Don't eat the trash.
That's a good question.
Can't we just,
do they eat the trash?
We can just can't just breathe rats and
you throw them in the dump and just have
him eat like,
I don't think they like fucking milk.
Could just have
pretty heady bravos get a
rat reading service releases.
When the dog got cancer,
did you see drastic rat?
Yeah,
but now we've got to
get rid of the rat shit.
Oh fuck dude.
Hey,
use it as fertilizer.
That can't be good for the dogs.
Mami Manoa,
boom,
boom.
Here's a fun hot minute.
When did he fight last?
He'd lost.
I thought he starched homeboy though.
The wrestler
who?
Oh,
nor dean to lab.
He's very good.
That guy's good.
He's a nasty he his knee Tristar.
Yeah,
he is.
He looks at the,
he looks at the guy with the roses
and mouth from Mike Tyson's punch out.
Does he?
Does he does Darren tills got
some prominent cheekbones,
Huh?
Yeah,
but that's why he got that nickname.
The gorilla.
He looks like he's got at
least 5% in the end are tall.
Do you think someone
gave him that nickname?
The gorilla?
Yeah,
I hope so too.
That bums me out when
people give themselves,
I call myself to gorilla.
I hated,
I hated my nickname,
the twisters so much.
I hated that shit cause I
just sounds pretty homosexual.
The twister because Hagan and John,
Jack would always call me.
That was shit because of the guillotine.
They called the rustlers
guilty and the twister,
and I asked her [inaudible].
I'm like,
how do you say the twister and Portuguese?
And he goes,
total.
Now they're like,
oh,
can you call me that?
That sounds way better.
Yeah,
call me that.
They would never call me that.
I kept calling me twister and it stopped.
It started.
It started sounding good when I compete
and people would start yelling at
Twitter.
Then I thought,
okay,
okay.
I think I like it now.
I did get man taught her Nado torn.
I just kept thinking of the game,
the twister and the
yellow dots and the dots.
Yeah.
You should get a tattoo
that says El Toronado.
Yes.
Fucking never stuck.
Aren't you get sticking right now.
Now I'm going to call it.
Yeah,
that's way better than the twist
or that's a great word though.
It sounds dangerous to
go to notch this summer.
Toronado there you go.
That would be a great license,
but if you could fit all
those words torn on Tornado,
Tornado,
it doesn't have no,
it's there's an a different tornado.
No,
there's tour Rod.
Nado Tornado.
There's a,
there's an a in their
English is Tornado Tornado,
is it?
No,
I'm just told that the aids.
What I know,
I though that's what makes it dope.
You can't,
you can't pick your nickname like county
called me big brown for the longest.
Like I'm like,
why is it because you're
being fucking brown.
That's just what,
and then I would walk place.
People would yell up big browns.
Okay,
well fuck that stock.
Right.
Brown.
That's a good nickname.
Kind of fun.
It's fine.
Yeah.
That's good.
The other one's name dope.
Oh yeah.
That's a whole,
that's just from you.
Yeah,
that's it.
But even when you were doing taekwondo,
no one gave me a nickname.
No,
Joe.
No.
When I was,
uh,
playing pool a lot,
I was Joe the comedian,
GSP with us on the podcast.
He just did on your turning sidekick.
Holy Shit.
Talk about endorsers.
Critiquing it as good for a half an hour.
Has Gone on about his power is incredible.
No Shit.
George.
Holy Shit.
As GSP going off on Joe Rogan.
Yeah,
we trained a little afterwards.
I switched my mats out.
I had those a zebra mats that are
super smooth and no Bueno to at all.
Dee Dee Dee on,
on throwing kit DVD.
Was it 1997 some sort
of a video will still,
you know people,
John Danaher just put out a DVD.
Well he put out a video on demand.
I bet he paid
wranglers in fucking under Armour.
Todd's of course,
but a DVD,
fanny pack game,
fanny pack.
Uh Yeah,
I would uh,
I would do that.
George and I,
we,
we went over the front
leg side kick first,
which is like the most important part.
The attorney sidekick.
Once you get the front leg side kick down,
you understand how that works,
then you turn and then it's basically
you're turning and then throwing the front
leg side kick.
It's just going to get
an extra push to it.
But most people do the front,
like psychic rom there needs to low,
it needs too low.
You lose all power.
Crazy shit.
You think you fight.
If he's going to fight at 55 [inaudible]
five 100% and he's only 185 pounds,
she has paid 55 and he's only doing it
once and it's going to be the winner of
Conor.
Khabib,
he started doing this is you look at this.
This is what Wonderboy does.
It's CR.
That's weird.
That sideways stance is
hard to fuck with man.
I used to spar with this
guy named Larry Jones.
Larry Johns was this dude who was like,
he was like six foot two but his
fucking legs when all the way up to his
armpits,
man had along that.
The guys who was standing in front
of the bag when you first walked,
by that time,
John Lee,
John's another tall dude,
Chinese dude,
black dude.
John [inaudible] was a beast that
could easily be a Chinese dude.
Yeah,
it could be.
if you heard it,
but he was like six foot two black
as coal dad walking by that Taiwan.
He just all bullshit.
Dude.
That guy hit so hard.
I saw him flat and a lot
of people with that too.
Um,
but anyway,
my friend Larry Jones,
I was too short,
you know,
I'm five,
eight when I would spar with him,
my legs were normal leg,
he was six,
two and I just could
not get past that front
leg side kick night man.
That front,
like psychic is so hard and they
can just move around with you.
It's basically like a jab and
they can move around with you.
You know,
it's like,
and they're safe.
Yeah.
You try and get an angle
trying to get an angle on them.
There's actually a thing on a hen Zos
Instagram the other day we had a photo of
Hixon throwing a sidekick and he was
talking about how Hixon like the sidekick
best for Valley Tudo.
Um,
because you know,
you never lost your base.
Like if you throw a roundhouse kick,
you throw the kid running around,
you reset it.
He was kind of throwing like
a front push kick side kick.
Yup.
And he would,
out of all the Gracies,
it looked like Hixon through it with
the most power because the hoist would
throw,
but it didn't look powerful.
But,
but when you watch hoists Sakuraba too,
when it was at the coliseum,
but that's a forgotten fight.
People Watch how hoist
would be on his back and,
and uh,
in sac was standing over him
and he was like purgatory.
Sakharova standing hoists,
throw side kicks off his back.
Dude Harney Dude,
better than anybody I've ever seen.
He's on his side and he was throwing
some serious side kicks off his back,
little soccer and fucking
up soc Robin's needs.
I've never seen anybody
remember Hixon did that too.
Finicky when Funai got Hixon down for
knocky broke Hickson's orbital people
forget like that.
What?
That was Hickson's greatest victory
because for Nakia was the guy that when
people were saying,
well,
he's such a good grappler,
if he went to the ground with Hixon,
he could,
he could actually hang with Hixon.
But he cracked Hicks.
Him with a big right hand hurt him
fucked up as I broke his orbital and they
went to the ground.
And as we knock you standing over
Hixson Hixson fucked his knees up,
fucked his knees up with
side kicks off of his back.
That's huge.
Huge.
And no one practices that shit.
No.
And a practice.
Hanzo,
uh,
would practice up kicks specifically just
just in case he was in that purgatory
position where he got boom,
it worked against old leg talk.
Tara.
Remember that?
That was the first upkick for us.
Appkit Kale.
And I think it was either,
I think Marillo Bustamonte did it to
Jerry Bolander or it was either Fabio's
years yelled at book Bolando or
Bustamante to Belinda upkick.
Boom.
Took 'em out.
Bam.
You know the Kickstarter now,
legal and combat Jujitsu.
They're illegal.
Yes.
Kicks.
He go,
Shit.
How hard was that to get?
Um,
you know what an amateur MMA
UPP kicks her legal gate guard.
You know what?
I'm Sassy.
Amateur MMA UPP kicks your legal,
we added them to combat you just because
guys are getting too comfortable in
purgatory,
just standing over guys.
They didn't want to go into anybody's
guard that could kill the show.
So now with the threat,
it's really easy to deal with upkick.
So all they gotta do just get to
their needs and start passing.
You gotta engage.
Yeah.
Just engage if all you get,
because you rarely see up kicks in Nma
rarely because they're so easy to deal
with.
But the threat of them will keep you,
you know,
I'll either away from purgatory
or get on your knees and,
and
commenced to passing.
That's what it's all about.
You about to say Musashi.
Dockery yeah,
he knocked out jocker right.
Where that triangle choke though.
He fell into a triangle.
Yeah,
there's been probably,
I would say I see Roy McDonald door
like seven total up kicks it history,
something like that there.
So we're not adding up kicks to
combat Jujitsu to increase Kaos.
We're adding it to increase the ground
says don't stand over the guy with pass.
Let's go.
Yeah,
let's get to that.
Smart.
Super Smart.
Yeah.
I Love Combat Jujitsu.
I love the rule set.
I love what it does.
It opens up,
uh,
the,
the reality aspect.
Do you understand that you
can't just do certain things.
You're going to get
smacked in the face hard.
It keeps your Jujitsu honest.
That's it.
Don't get too crazy,
dude.
I forgot to Holly Holm
versus Megan Anderson.
That's a barn burner.
Oh yeah.
It's a big fight for Anderson.
Is her her first shot at
the UFC and his right away.
Holly Holm.
Is there any,
because they could give Cyborg a match.
A good,
good competition.
Ryerson.
Uriah favor.
Favor.
If there's not a woman who's
going to give her any challenge?
Uriah February.
Would it be illegal Cyborg to find a man?
No.
It's me movement.
What are you talking about?
You know what I'm saying?
It has nothing to do with that.
No.
May choose about sexual assault credit.
I know brother and I'm
not saying you're a fever,
did that,
but you paint the story market.
She comes out with me too.
It just beats the shit out of a
dualism of gallons in her corner
and then in the secondary blinds,
dean comes out of the floor
right behind the smoke.
Cm pumps,
five main event.
Cm punk against Cyborg.
That would be great.
That's what I said
before,
or not,
bro.
What would she do to him?
She would knock his
head off in the fucking,
it was like a cartoon.
Ooh.
Where'd you guys saying that?
Why don't you guys saying that?
A guys could never,
uh,
at an MMA fighter kid
would always be a girl.
Right?
Why you sent out when we're talking about
Ronda Rousey back in the day that can,
Ronda Rousey said that he said
Ron could beat Mike Tyson,
Tyson.
He got shit for them.
But you know,
the flying arm bar maybe?
No,
you'd still a slamming again today.
He's like 50.
Yeah,
I did.
Probably has some of his rough.
She,
she would be a disaster right now.
But,
um,
I think the rough as he is he doing bad,
uh,
not doing bad.
It's just,
you know,
when you,
especially as me growing up with,
with Mike Tyson,
you think they say never meet your heroes.
You know,
so it's like,
I think of him as that Mike
Tyson and my head went on.
Then when I saw him,
you know he had sweats on and
some white new balances and you,
he's out of shape.
Parents went to this
fashion balance right away.
You're like,
is fashions off?
Well Dude,
this on Sunday afternoon leisure time,
like it's the middle of
the was on your podcast.
Larry is with your fashion.
You really give a fuck.
They didn't wear sweatpants.
Show respect.
What is it with you in fashion
that makes no sense to them?
I would have never brought it up.
Him wearing sweatpants and
new balance and be like,
yeah,
he wants to be comfortable.
Really?
Yeah.
Pride.
No,
I don't want to fight.
It's like,
it's like I saw a,
I don't get it.
It's like I saw Bret Hart in Calgary
and I go out and they're like,
he's in the front row and I go out
there and he's in matching sweatsuit,
tuck the bottom of thought.
Fuck Brownouts Saturday night,
man,
you have my show.
Wait,
wait,
wait.
He's in Canada and he's
a former pro wrestler,
right?
Yeah.
He talking about,
okay,
he's in Canada.
That's like a three piece suit up there.
What are you doing?
What are you doing Saturday night,
Saturday,
you're out on the town.
Can we sweat?
So they,
that's how they roll up.
They just happy.
It's not 150 below zero.
They're very happy.
They weren't something nice
and light judge people though,
man.
Probably a nice sweat suit,
right?
It's kind of like the
McGregor matching grace,
you know?
And then the white one with that.
The fuck is wrong with that.
Looks still looks fresh.
Your fucking
dude.
I have terrible fashion.
You can't listen.
You don't though.
You have GI was a nice
shirt yet your fanny pack,
fanny packs are back in the
game that brought that shit.
Come on.
I want her back.
I want 10% of the credit for,
should I just post this thing on high?
Might have more than 10%
of the credit I'm being,
I'm being humble.
You're,
you're the guy who I know who's right or
die about fanny packs and then cro cop
still fucks with it,
but he's on of where and how big
of an impact and I had to Croatia,
they don't know what time it is.
They all wear fanny packs,
you know?
Yo Dude,
I wore fanny packs back in the
90s now you're ever stopped.
Know your first team all fanny pack.
Damn.
Nor deep to labs going off.
I just standing up and
slap the shit out of him.
Yeah.
No,
he's good man.
Nor Dean's.
Very good.
I never stopped with a fanny pack.
No,
you just ride through it even.
Yeah.
People like to chose fanny pack and like,
I know man.
This shit on.
Yes.
I the shit out of him.
I'm always out of stock.
My boy wants when bad hire.
I made.com we were at Disneyland.
Are we close to MMA and the Olympics?
Yeah.
Yeah,
we are.
Holy Shit.
They're working on it.
Yeah.
They're trying to imagine that.
Well,
it would be a candidate.
It would be amazing.
I would rush or just when
all the belts are they,
what about,
we had some seconds,
man.
Fucking situation.
I mean Russia,
it'd be tough,
man.
Whoa.
It really depends.
Entirely drug testing,
but they'll figure it out.
I mean Russians when it comes,
you know,
boxed and combat sports.
Russia is really pretty fucking good
with Dagestan be considered Russia.
But the thing is though is what I
was putting it under the same banner.
Yeah.
But the thing is,
what would happen is if it did
become huge in the Olympics,
then people would realize like,
you know how guys like
Floyd Mayweather and uh,
so many different professional boxers got
their start as a Olympic gold medalist
and then went on to become
these huge superstars in boxing.
Loma Chanko is another good example.
When you have like a real
great amateur background,
people get super amped
up for go pro Andre Ward.
Yeah.
Anthony Joshua.
Yup.
You get super amped up about seeing
those guys go pro in America.
It's a little different though,
for the reason when it comes to boxing.
Yeah.
Because we liked the other can we use to
with Mark Breland member of those days
with a Tyrrell pigs,
we used to love it.
We used to love it when a
guy was a Olympic gold metal.
Pernell Whitaker,
you know ray Mercer.
Yeah.
I said,
let Andre Ward though.
It's still,
you know,
and he looked at this leg lock
Deontay wilder has a bronze medal.
This was Shane bags.
He started boxing like 21 oh shit.
Anytime he hit them double
outside Ashley's and MMA,
they're risky.
What such a weird position
to find yourself in.
If a guy can punch in the face and again
it goes back to your combat Jujitsu,
all Monta.
Yep.
It goes back to your combat Jujitsu.
You understand what positions are like
super dangerous cause there's positions
at guys regularly practice in Jujitsu
that will get you fucked up if a guy can
punch you in the face.
Exactly.
That's what it's all about.
Combat Jujitsu is such a good idea.
Thank you man and so happy
and is going well right
before he does it.
Does the UFC being acquired by
ESPN affect the fight pass and not
cause?
Are they going to continue
with the fight pass?
Are you sure?
As a matter of fact,
the president of fight pass
when that deal went through,
emailed me personally,
the let me know.
He goes,
listen,
this is,
this deal has nothing.
This.
Look at this game oversight body triangle.
It's deep,
deep,
deep.
Pat,
can you hang in there for 40 seconds?
I don't think so.
Sino he's in trouble.
He's got a,
he's got a and he's
tapping into about the tap?
No,
it's on the chin.
Oh he's out.
What's broke?
His jaw.
Damn.
Yeah.
That's what they said.
Your boy problem you'd have to worry
about is now that people would have to
subscribe to ESPN.
Plus you get the full ESPN experience.
Now they're gonna have to
pay for that and fight paths.
Is that real?
That's real.
So fipass doesn't really change it or
they're not getting rid of bypass it all.
I don't like getting rid of it as far
as it grows and could be an issue.
I think the fan base stays.
How does that work though?
They're going to stream some
fights still on fight pass.
No,
I don't think so.
What do you mean ESPN is going to take
all that content cause he cause you have
right cause now ESPN plus and
ESPN platforms can have 30 fights.
Then ESPN is going to have
12 paper use at least.
So we have 42 fights a year now.
So there's no,
I could be wrong,
Jamie car if I'm wrong,
there's no fight pass card.
I don't think so.
I think he's just give me a database
for stuff like Eddie's old school fight
libraries and then you know that's I
so I don't think it's going to grow.
I think it's going to continue.
It's doing and stuff like Eddie's
my grow.
But people are mean.
I'll see more ESPN plus packaging.
That's a tough sell because I love it.
I think five passes.
Awesome.
And if you want to just go old school
and watch a bunch of great old fights is
the best format on the planet earth.
If you're a hardcore figure,
hardcore fan.
But I liked the fact that
we'd have the prelims,
some fights that you couldn't see
anywhere else but fight pass and then they
would have certain fight pass cards.
Well you win.
How many times did we watch you
fight companions with the entire car?
But now you can do it on these two up.
Look at that shit.
That is nothing.
I can do it on ESPN plus jail.
Yeah.
Could be.
You know you got to pay us Pam plus.
Is that fine?
Is that,
yeah,
but for another thing online,
it's digital.
Espn pluses,
digital APP.
Eddie,
what could he have same
as get out of this.
What could he do to get out of this?
Eddie,
he's got a peel that arm off his neck.
That's what I do late at this point,
right?
I mean get an answer to that spot.
A couple of things.
You've got to protect your neck obviously
and then he's got to get up to the leg
press position where he could get up
on like it's just doing a leg press,
pushing back that it relieves some of
the pressure and then eventually get over
to the side of the cinched bottom
triangle and try to break that shit apart.
Yeah,
you gotta break those body
triangle is a partner to move fast.
You got to prevent them from
happening in the first place.
You've got to be soon as
someone takes your back.
First thing is don't let it get too deep.
And by two deep,
that means body trying,
you know,
don't let that shit happen.
What were you to say,
Jamie?
That uh,
the fight pass thing and it's so,
uh,
the ESPN deal is us only it says,
so that'd be for us broadcast only at
five past is still for the rest of the
world.
Does,
that'd be the big difference.
Yeah.
I didn't even ask.
They just said,
dude,
don't even trip.
I don't know who they sent me.
They sent me an email saying,
don't worry about it.
Uh,
we,
we're,
we're not getting rid of a Ebi.
We,
we'd love you.
It's,
it's,
you know,
don't even trip.
Sure.
That's for a raise.
Did.
And so that means in,
so in America it's just going
to affect fight pass in the UFC.
Everyone else,
they're good to go.
But also they,
there's no really paper views outside.
Internationally,
they get it for free.
Like in Brazil,
all the,
all the stuff's free.
There's no paper used in Brazil.
Right.
They're watching on global.
Yeah.
They get it all free.
It's right there.
ESPN broadcast deal that includes 10
full UFC cards or primary ESPN channels,
uh,
on primary USP ESPN channels.
ESPN,
ESPN two along with the pre prelims
for a dozen UFC paper view events,
another 25 cards.
We'll stream on ESPN plus totaling
30 full events annually between ESPN
broadcasted streaming outlets.
All full fight cards are
expected to have 12 bouts.
Addition,
additional and shoulder UFC programs
such as Dana White's contender series,
a new all access series and pre and post
fight shows and more are also included
in the deal.
Oh,
that's interesting.
10 tough is done.
So cap has done tough.
Tough has done from my
understanding.
So did the Dana White's contenders shoes
was going to kind of be the focus now
what do you know?
Why would you,
I think that's good.
It's tough is a dying plus in mandate.
Those dudes stay in that house for
six weeks and all that crazy shit.
I don't like it.
Who you tone.
So they have,
so even with DC and steep bay who are,
you know,
light heavyweight champion of the world,
heavy weight champ of the world.
Those then you get the
insight on those guys.
Even those ratings suck Dick.
It's just not going well.
It's 27 seasons deed.
It's a tired format.
Yeah,
everyone's just over it and no more,
no stars come from anymore.
No.
What's it called out?
Your series is great.
Contender series is good.
Sean O'malley came from there.
Greg Hardy fighting on that.
You got some,
who is that guy that knocked out?
Thiago Alves didn't he
come from there as well?
A wrong about that.
I'm not sure.
The biggest one is Sean O'malley,
but then you're also
going to have a homeboy.
Why am I forgetting his name?
Sorry Dude.
The guy with the,
the with the arm.
Come on nick.
No,
Nick Newell is finally win streak.
Holy Shit.
Nick knew it was going to beat the shit.
Keep on the contenders.
He should not be on there.
You don't think so?
God know.
What do you think you for a world
title against just engaging,
but it's good to get him exposure.
Let people know how good he is.
I guess it depends how many people
are watching contenders trees.
You got some real
potential talent out there.
I think the real thing about what's
interesting about the contender series is
now people you'd never
heard of are very good.
I mean,
how many people do we know
that are just guys in the gym?
They're like,
dude,
that guy's fucking good.
Yeah,
and they've never bought a break.
They never fought or they've had one
amateur fight or something like that.
But you realize like when you see
them roll with like really good guys,
like Holy Shit,
this guy's like just a hair
below a worldclass level.
There's so many guys like that now
because it's one of those guys.
No,
no,
no.
And that's not what I'm saying.
I'm saying he has the potential to
face one of those guys in the contender
series.
I almost think it,
it's it.
That's the opposite of
what they should be doing.
Because I found my young dude,
I'm trying to get my break in and I'm
on the contender contingencies and he'd
give me nick news 17 five
to 17 and one fuck man,
why can't I find a young guy and this
coming from a guy who had three fights,
[inaudible] Roy Nelson the finale.
That's true.
I was like,
what do you want to blow up?
You gotta you gotta fight.
That's true.
It's not like they're fighting
the UFC world champion.
You know,
you gotta
you gotta go in there,
but other kids are fighting
that constantly saying,
I see what you're saying.
It should be a lower Christian.
Yeah.
For someone there going like,
dude,
I get fucking,
I draw Nick Newell.
Sean O'malley was fighting,
guys have his same,
similar,
blew it up,
just knocking dudes out.
Now he's a stock out.
Maybe it'll be like one or two fights
and then they'll get nick in the UFC.
It should be one.
So they're familiar with them,
but he,
he's going gonna be tough man.
If he,
if he gets into that division
can be tough to beat.
A lot of it's inspiring story too.
I don't,
I would,
I would market the shit out with that man.
Yeah.
I think they're worried
that if he gets head kick,
which he's never been knocked
out from the head kick,
they're worried with his arm.
Right.
If you can't defend it,
he gets brutally knocked out.
I'm like,
how would you,
how can you put that guy on TV?
But you've got to realize too,
think about how much your arm weighs.
Like,
I
mean,
it's not an advantage by any
stretch of the imagination,
but the rest of him is bigger and heavier.
Like if,
if what is,
I mean,
how much do you think
he's missing 10 pounds?
You see?
Know how much,
how much does an average farm way,
Jamie,
that's gotta be 10 pounds?
No,
eight pounds.
Six pounds,
dude,
I think mine is about a hundred.
How might,
how seriously,
like from his guys,
the grapple,
there's a guy that grapples with that
leg and his upper body is that of like a
dude that's two AP classes above the guys.
He's fighting,
what does it say,
Jamie?
Eight pounds.
What?
The whole arm.
But that's the whole arm weighs
about 5% of your body weight.
Okay.
But that's the whole arm.
See,
nick has the upper arm.
He had cast down to the elbow
down past the elbows right here.
So let's say his,
yeah,
it's not that big of an event.
There was a rep,
there's a wrestler,
world champion.
Connie's next.
Oh Shit.
But Jason,
I fell on some tough times.
He started off super hot
and then lost his last two.
Who did he fight?
He stepped way.
Laura's law.
That's realized.
Crazy idea.
That was crazy llamas.
His world title contender.
No one wants to fucking names.
You're going to fucking
monster all across the board.
Yeah.
Did I go?
Okay,
you got llamas.
You beat Shazam.
Skelly.
Pardot llamas too.
He lost a Mowgli.
Damn man.
It's tough.
He got knocked out and then he comes
back and he lost a Mowgli this of the
night.
This is a tough fight,
man.
Army mach one or my Connie might be the
toughest fight out of all three of those
war than,
Oh Ricardo Lamas.
He's dangerous.
This Ricardo Lamas.
Yeah,
you're right.
You're right.
But this mock one armor.
Connie's a wild motherfucker.
He does a lot of crazy shit.
Llamas just chills in the top
six but I mean he's just there.
Well class get some.
I'm going to have him on with his dad.
A car alarm has been like leaving
him alone if he thinks I forgot.
I haven't forgot his dad is a look.
A Cuban exile.
His Dad left Cuba and
his dad Joe in here too.
No,
no,
no.
His Dad speaks perfect.
He speaks perfect English and Spanish too.
Yeah,
I know Ricardo does.
I get to talk to him.
I just didn't want to fuck
with him before his fight.
He's got a big fight.
Makes Sense in Chicago.
Yeah,
that is very interesting.
We were looking at the
commercial from UIC chick,
Steve Bay versus Daniel Cormier.
Yay.
Great fight.
Ooh,
interesting.
Tough.
What's the latest with Jon Jones?
What's going on dude?
I wish I knew still.
He's still waiting to see what exactly
is spent in his but where does he's going
to fight,
you know,
fairly soon.
Oh really?
I route so hard for that dude.
Me Too man.
But why?
Cause he's a beast to bad
mothers and I think in,
I think in his heart he's a very good guy.
I was getting to,
yes,
I really do mean that he does fucked
up things and he makes mistakes.
But I think John in his
heart is a very good guy.
I really
do.
I just think he just makes poor
choices and he's wild and you know,
and,
and one of the reasons why we
love them is that wildness.
I liked that.
He's wild.
Yeah,
I don't like that he hurts people,
but he is,
it's typically when guys act like that,
I usually ride them off
like fuck that dude.
But with him,
he's so talented.
I literally think he's the best
of all time to raise the octagon.
I want to see him back and I
think comes back at heavyweight.
I think he beats the brakes off.
Brock,
I think he's come back.
Fight is Brock and then he fights for
the heavyweight title against the winter.
Steepy DC.
That would be amazing.
That's what I would do.
This pen.
You liked this deal.
Here's 2019
did I have the apples?
I had the weirdest dream that I was,
that I had shorts on with no underwear
and are jerked off in my car.
Oh No.
I came all over myself and I couldn't
figure out what to do and then I had to go
and meet some friends and I was outside
the door and for some reason Kyle
Kingsbury was in there.
I liked this problem.
I'm like,
I'm covered with my own TJ's
and I don't have any underwear.
And I just had my shorts on like,
and then I woke up going,
what the fuck is wrong
with a wet dream though?
No.
Really?
You busted in your drill
is the weirdest dream.
I've never had a dream.
It's your job to my car.
I've never had.
Which car was it though?
This is a big camper.
The car,
was it Joe?
I don't know.
We had a dream where you
dropped off spark a jack.
I've met Jim when I'm having sex.
Yeah,
of course.
It's my bed.
It's like,
wait a minute.
You had a dream,
you had sex and you're actually
busted up my wet dream.
Eddie.
I had those where a myth real.
I had to figure out I was going to meet
some people and apparently didn't have
any underwear on.
I didn't have a shirt on and I had know.
I was like,
I had to crack the door up and I'm like,
dude,
I've got a problem.
Look,
you got to help me up,
and then I woke up going,
what the fuck?
Kind of thought is that it's coming from.
It's rare.
I remember my dreams.
It's weird.
Do you remember yours?
It's writ.
I remember my last mine last night,
I was walking around,
I was backstage at Bella tour.
I was going to fight someone I
can't remember and I was like,
I'm not doing this.
I mean it was like pleading to,
I'm not going to do it.
I'm not fucking ready man.
I'm going to do that.
I don't need this.
I'm like,
are you going to go out there?
no.
That's a weird thing.
That's like one of them.
I got to go back to high
school and graduate thing,
have those dreams,
all that you can never remember your your
locker combination for your locker and
like how do I open this motherfucker?
My dream,
my nightmares were credits.
I was too,
too many credits shy of graduating high
school and they were making me go back
another year.
You're not?
No.
You graduate high school.
I did.
But you remember like when you,
when you were in high school there was
always that one dude that somehow or
another fucked up and had
to repeat the senior year.
So he's 18 everybody else's 17 is
fucking dude is in high schools.
The jeep wrangler just sad.
He's sad.
He's losing a year of his light workout.
I have this recurring nightmare that I
don't think it's a post to be a nightmare
I think is supposed to be a great dream.
But it always turns into a nightmare
because like when I used to Dj at Strip
clubs,
I had a good time.
It was always fun and
then I dream about it.
I dream about it.
And the,
the problem is to be a strip club Dj,
you got to,
you got to know your cds and the girls
that are going up and you're matching up
the songs with the girls,
you gotta be sharp because they
all want those different songs.
Exactly.
So in my dream,
I think it's supposed to be a great train,
but I can never read the cds
and the managers get mad at me.
I'm like,
I'm like what girls on stage?
And I'm like,
I'm going.
And the only CB that I remember,
the only one is the crystal method
because that was my goto CD.
No other cds.
I'm like,
oh I could always pull that
one out as your default.
Yeah.
Cause you know you got to change the
song every two minutes and 45 seconds
because every song means money for,
for the club.
They're all getting lap dances.
So if you let a song go three and a half,
four minutes,
the manager get on your ass,
what the fuck?
It's three and a half minutes.
It's very stressful.
So if there's a girl,
a girl bust about to go on stage and
15 seconds before she goes on stage,
she goes,
skip me.
I got a lap dance and we're fucked up.
I'm like,
Oh shit.
I got 15 seconds to find
a replacement and to,
to change the this.
I got a plan.
Yeah.
So in my dream I'm having
a fucking nightmare.
I'm like,
I can't see the girl on stage
and I can't see my sister.
Yeah,
it's a total nine.
I'm like,
Oh my God,
I'm gonna get fired.
What am I going to do now?
I never figured in my dream ever do
I realize that I make money teaching
Jujitsu.
Never.
It's always I lose my job,
my,
what am I going to do now?
And then I wake up,
I'm like,
ah,
I teach Jiu Jitsu.
I'm fine.
You're the one in between the tracks by
guidelines and Joe and bring up Dandy on
stage seven.
But he never did it that way.
He didn't have the fig strip club.
Oh No,
no,
no.
I did.
You have to have the faith.
No,
you have to have it,
but you have to because
if you talk regularly,
no,
it was always,
it was always my Simpsons.
Dj Strip clubbing.
All right guys.
Put those hands together for London.
Oh No.
But you have to say you have to do
that goofy voice to cut through.
Otherwise people can't hear you.
If you just get on a mic and a strip
club and you just talk like Kelly's on
table seven over,
they won't cut through.
They won't cut through.
Well,
not only that,
like it has to have some drama to it.
Right.
You can't just go,
oh,
here's Monica.
She doesn't like doing this job,
but here show you guys.
You got to have that check
or that there's disease.
She's got some unfortunate
to goofy's Jason.
Hopefully she'll find a good guy.
I leave this job.
Chels made some terrible decisions.
Checked her out table
that that is unfortunate.
But now you gotta go all out
childhood.
She's been in bed 25 foster homes.
Just hook her up.
Just come on.
Jason Knight.
Tough motherfucker.
That's fairly common.
The Country Diaz
look at that fucking knows.
Man That knows his to take it.
Some punches,
son,
he ran his name,
his nickname the country does,
cause he's very similarly the Diaz
brothers minus the domestic abuse charges.
Well,
very fucking debt.
Domestic abuse thing is bomber man.
W do we don't know the facts though.
Dewey Jail Knicks guys sent me something.
Those friend data.
Yeah.
Dating some girl.
It doesn't cast now
she's actually a stalker and really good.
He's a really good person.
I'm like,
Oh fuck you're.
Thanks Bro.
Yeah.
Did Jason Knight um,
nasty off his back?
Yeah.
Great glass quick.
He's an Alan Belcher student.
Alan Belcher's Jujitsu is
pretty awesome for MMA.
This kid's been talking so much shit.
Americani Mr Finland,
he's talking so much Belcher versus uh,
Theresa Rusa Mar porous.
We beat the shower.
One of the greatest fights
of all fucking thigh.
But everybody was scared of that.
I saw him a week later.
Right in there.
We put them in.
He had it rude.
Some are in a twist into it.
I saw him a week later and
I was so impressed by it.
I scared him.
Or You thought he was Mike Tyson?
I was like,
Bro,
it's like Jesus Christ.
What you did was insane and
small at the time in a twister.
He had them in the truck,
almost finished him.
Rusa Mar gets out,
gets out,
has Alan Belcher,
all sorts of leg lock trouble and Al
Belter just dismantled all that shit and
beat the fuck out.
Dean lister and who else
was it Tom to blast?
No,
he brought in,
uh,
for that fight for a month.
He brought in deanlets during
Dobby Ramos who's in the UFC.
That'd be Ramos is really
good at like locks too.
So he had,
he had,
he had dean Lester Dobby.
Ron was on his legs for a month.
He said the first two weeks he
tapped out probably 500 times,
but then he started learning how to
stop the leg locks to the a month.
Then he went into it,
beat the shit out and then he made,
he made a DVD called immunity.
How to stop lag la.
Remember that immunity?
Alan Belcher.
Like he's over there talking,
dude,
I'm telling you homeboy,
he's talking so much shit.
Then when they did the posts,
you know Wayne's,
when they always interview,
he was like,
I'm going to beat the shit out of him.
He was going hard in the pace.
Well Jason Knight is one of the few
fighters in the UFC where they can't show
his flag.
Was this flags get the fucking Mississippi
still has the confederate flag and
their state.
Yeah,
they're proud of that shit.
Jamie,
can you get the fight on
that screen as well please?
That is it.
That is fucking crazy.
Which satisfy the night written all
over his big ass screen right here.
Sharp while Y'all turned
my my next all stiff.
What are we doing it right?
They're like,
oh fuck three screens in here.
This is like a God damn sports bar.
It's like we're at buffalo
wild wings minus the wings.
This is a very,
very interesting fight.
Amir Khan.
He's been talking crazy shit,
huh?
Oh dude was going so hard in the paint.
He goes,
this is a long trip for you to come
just for one round to get knocked out.
She's going super hard.
Then you just trying to get them
emotional cause he from England?
Yeah.
Does he live in?
No,
he lives in Finland.
We did it.
At least he did for a while.
I don't know he,
they used to call him
Mister Finland I think.
I think,
yeah.
Nights.
The underdog here.
Okay.
Well I mean he kind of has to be
after those two losses in a row,
but our mayor Connie was a guy who burst
on the scene a few years back and you
know,
was really promising.
But we haven't yet.
People don't talk about it much.
Oh No.
They will feel,
oh shit.
Oh,
jump on him.
Oh good.
Happy Guard America.
This isn't what he wants.
You don't want to get in these scrambles
and this straight up cockfight with
your with nightmares pulled.
Guard quit.
Yeah.
Tony want to them to look at that.
Please don't do that.
He's controlling his biceps
and talking shit to him.
Hit.
Don't do that though.
Oh,
good posture.
And he did a good job at avoiding
any kind of guard attacks.
Yeah.
The way he did that by
planting down those biceps,
a very small slice of control,
and then he postured up at the
permit time broke through those legs.
He's been doing his homework
and he's telling him that too,
like,
you ain't getting shit off on me.
Let's snake tattoo hanging
over his shoulders.
Interesting.
It's like a Mandy to the main stage.
Yes.
It's very similar.
Just talking.
We got hurt.
He got hurt.
He's,
you get a motion jabs or touching him.
He was having a problem with that.
I did.
He has a lot of scar tissue on his face.
If you look at his face like she looks
like a great whites knows it's fucking,
it's just all sorts of
shit all over as well.
That style,
I mean that crazy bulldog style
doesn't really work these days,
man.
Once you get to upper echelon level,
it works until you,
you can't take a shot anymore because
your workspace just gets smashed in too
much.
Then when you get,
the technicians are like,
all right,
cool man.
That's just engage you.
Exactly.
That's what you want to do.
Cool.
Yeah.
Guys just are smart.
He's mock.
Juan just keeps looking for that right
hook counter and he's doing it real nice.
I like what he's doing.
I like his jab to Oh,
there you go.
Oh,
I'm here.
Connie is a good wrestler too,
is very good.
Yeah,
that's his background.
Oh Shit.
Okay.
He just keeps more of that damn.
Look at them.
It's comfortable in there.
Did it.
That leg kick hurt him.
You think that inside one,
it always hurts.
I think sucks.
Especially when you get
kicked right above the knee.
Oh,
that's a fucking terrible feeling.
It just feels like you're hoping your
your ligament stay together and they do.
Dude.
How much always do,
but every time you get hit,
they're like,
oh damn.
Wheel kicks.
Dude.
How about Amanda Nunez Kicks
Against Raquel Pennington.
Pentance at that first cake.
She had surgery on that.
Oh Shit.
Doodie stomped right on that knee
and folded them a little bit.
You see that he's throwing
a nice variety of kicks.
I liked that.
Well,
he's got to do that.
Get guys,
guys
that are fighting the day,
there's a whole bunch of them that
they don't really any kicks still.
They're still out there and they
don't throw anything at the,
at the light,
at the latter levels.
They kind of mix it all up cause you have,
you shouldn't mix heavyweight
tegular cause you know what you know,
you know I love Damien Maia fucking
more than any other fighter out there,
right.
I think bye bye now.
Oh Shit.
Oh Damn.
Damn God,
we should have stayed on top.
You should have stayed on top.
I'm still her.
No,
he's still hurt.
Amir Khan.
He's still hurt.
He got fucked up coach.
Oh Shit.
He cracked him.
Oh
no shit.
That was,
he didn't go.
Oh Shit Dude.
What the fuck is he doing?
He likes fighting off his back.
He likes his recovering.
Yeah,
but look,
he's in mission control here.
This ain't bad.
I say bad at all
right there.
Just triangle his legs.
It's all he's got to do.
Oh,
it'd be triangle this legs.
You'd get them in a dead orchard.
Does he know singling out that?
Yeah,
he knows it.
But what he's trying to
do is clear the neck.
That's the main thing is trying to do.
He's going to try,
he's trying to get invisible collar at
this point or some kind of meat hook or
something with a stupid,
he's got,
oh shit.
He's got them.
He's got a 10 seconds.
He's got them in Vertiv.
Oh,
he got out.
Shit.
Look at that Dark Hilton.
Go for it.
10 seconds.
You're couple of shots.
Look at him.
Awesome.
You ain't talking shit anymore.
How about he started talking shit.
How about he stood up?
Starts I can shoot
this kid.
Oh,
you went to the wrong corner down.
They
fucked up.
That was awesome.
But getting British based on the
night caught him with some good shots.
Hurt him badly.
Hurt them bad.
40 seconds left to fucking
go down to guard like,
I don't care if you liked
it or not a bad idea.
I'm going to triangle.
Ah,
is that a man?
If that fight was two minutes longer,
he could have caught him in something.
He was scrambling.
You've got 30 seconds on top of him.
30 you know how hard it is
to get a finished 30 seconds.
It all depends on is it the way
only a of pulling guard.
It's so suicidal.
Like people say.
Why?
Why is it so hard for
Damien Maia to pull guard?
He'll sit on his button.
People don't want to get on top of them.
Yeah,
they make us stand at that.
Look at that.
Cause that's literally
my kids can't win any other way here we go
round to Emmett.
Connie got fucked up in
that first weekend night.
Did he still confident?
But he's a little bit like off fuck and
Emmer Connie still make taking big deep
breaths.
Dude.
He got hurt.
That
one uppercut really fucked him up.
Anyone else just ripped
my hardest fuck for night.
Yeah,
I'm at right now.
Right.
Well marked on a at Connie's.
He's a tough guy.
I like watching him fight,
but I also like a guy coming
back from two two fights down.
Did you lose three in a row?
It'd be,
it'd be tough.
His career be in trouble,
man.
Well these findings,
the one I've seen him,
how dare you dude.
One FC is putting on some
good fucking shows God boys
get to,
but can be into the UFC
and there's Bella Tor.
He's like,
the problem with one fc
is just about exposure.
They've got some great Thai
fighters over there in Asia.
One FC is huge,
huge,
huge to this giant reaches
like a billion households.
Yeah.
Beth Gaskins.
Huge Star.
No,
that in Asia.
He is,
oh,
look at this talking to you,
a seasoned agents to now son.
Yeah,
it is.
But one FC.
I'm telling you,
Brendan,
it is very big overseas.
I know.
It's big.
I know it's big.
If you're not in the UFC,
if you're not in the UFC,
it's a tough goal,
man.
It is.
It's a tough go.
But it's not over.
One FC is catching up in Asia.
I mean,
they're bigger than
Bellah tours over there.
They're building.
It doesn't really do age.
Exactly,
but that's our number two.
Right.
Or number two in America's Beltour.
Well,
no,
towards getting bigger.
Right.
It's bigger.
I mean,
they're in Europe.
They're obviously just had that card
and one what they're heavyweights,
uh,
tournament.
They're doing it.
They're killing it right now.
Yeah.
You got jail fade or coming up.
You got Ryan Bader Mitrione but
they need a heavyweight champion.
Yeah,
Michael.
Then in page,
you see that they don't
have a heavyweight champion.
Can I have one now?
Under the year?
Yeah.
Great.
That many big guys.
It's Ryan Bader.
It could be issues,
right?
Because he's a light heavyweight and
he's the light heavyweight champ,
but maybe fights better at at heavyweight
than he does it line everywhere.
It's true.
She felt Davis' head kick Kale.
That was crazy.
Davis looks good.
That was nasty.
Amir Khan.
Ooh.
Inside night talking shit.
Now I have some comments.
Americani got that Nice Jab,
right Hook Combo.
Yeah.
That right hand he throws
this looks for that show.
We clipped him.
Damn.
He's got a good ride,
Huh?
Oh,
nice uppercut to we mixed it up.
We're missing Colorado going,
God,
these guys are sweat.
Why doesn't he just hit
him with a right hand?
Yeah.
Cal.
You'd be like,
why?
What is it?
You just know Calico cat.
Keep your hands up.
Why does he throw the front kick?
Oh,
shoot him again.
He's hurt,
guilt,
guilty and coming in hot note pads again.
Yeah.
You can't get it as a triangle on the
body and doing a good job at defending
you.
Want to give that first round 10,
eight.
What'd you
Nah,
no,
no.
Maybe he might been down
the rules with the number.
What's the new rule?
The new
a scoring system.
What is it?
It,
the new scoring system is when
you show like a clear advantage,
you'd have to have someone look at it.
But a clear advantage is the difference
between like winning and winning.
Like clearly he clearly
won that first round.
I would have to look at it like how they,
how they,
uh,
frame it.
Now I think we have a real problem being
imprisoned by that 10 point system.
I think the 10 point system is stupid.
Pretty much happened there.
What do you think about
the recently there's been a
bunch of early standups from
the ground while the Leon Roberts
one with Damien Maia and uh,
uh,
Huseman was ridiculous.
What the wizard Riddick
that was super is ridiculous that
someone not knowing what's going on.
Not only that,
I mean you're dealing with a fighter
that is taking a fight on last minute
notice against a super dominant wrestler
and he essentially is in a great
position and could maybe get his back
and that's just biggest advantage.
You fuck them.
I'm Arconic.
Takes him down now.
Here.
Yeah.
He felt was another fire recently
when they were on the ground,
the guy was like side controller,
the mount,
and then the ref stood them up like that.
That same a chili card.
There's also in the girls fight where
the female referee let them just stay on
there,
but with no engagement.
I'm like,
stand them up right now,
officer.
She doesn't want to be down there.
She does.
No one's interacting.
Let's go chase it nights.
He's got a fucking wicked mission control.
He pulls to that Michigan lateral.
Very nice.
Got immediately right now he
could hit a triangle right here.
Made huck look at that.
Oh
yeah.
Has he been made?
Connie ain't doing shit
on the ground either.
He's not getting,
I mean he might be doing okay defensively,
but he's not getting shit off often.
No,
he's threatened nonstop down there,
which to me should be
a win for Jason Knight.
Jason,
I'd gone for a leg lock here.
I thought about it.
Amir,
Connie Austan he's losing and so he goes
to the ground but leg lock right here.
Oh Shit.
It's like a around a piece maybe.
Maybe the judges.
The judges for sure.
Given that the American
honey that's it's one,
one,
one.
Unless anything with
him on the ground zero.
He still can.
You still took them down sucks though.
Cause Jason Knight was doing work and
threatened him the entire time in the gun.
Get the gift of a Connie.
He's one of the defensive.
That's the flaws in our judging is,
is it's a giant.
It's fucking insane.
I feel like it should be
like a hundred points system.
I feel like there should never
be any up five minute rounds.
There should never be any standup.
Yeah,
I'm with you.
Why you standing in lockdown have forever
five minutes by the time they get to
the ground,
like there's not any get downs.
Like if there's so boring on the feet,
they're not.
They're not doing what you do guys,
just holding position Shit.
Just the fight.
That's just the way.
Got The fuck out of chance in in four
minutes to get back up to the feet when
the over,
because without
this Brendan,
this is what happens if you could,
if they stand them up
because they're holding,
then guys,
why would they learn Jujitsu
if they get taken down?
If a strike gets taken out,
all you gotta do is get good at holding
and the Rep's going to stand them up.
That's what it leads to and it fucks a
sport up round three you can't have that.
That gives,
that gives a strike or a reason to not
learn Jujitsu and just hold and look,
look to the referee standing
up or learn wrestling.
Keep winning by just holding him down.
One take done.
Then you got to learn how
to fight off your back.
God,
you got to learn how to fight.
You got to push the sport.
You can't go backwards.
I'm Eric standing,
looking for a take down again
and standing up the fight.
That takes everything backwards and it
makes it so you don't have to look into
it and trying to win the fight though.
It's an issue that you could say
the same thing about them standing.
That happens all the time standing.
No one says shit about that.
We can't put them to the ground.
Why not?
We do an in combat Jiu Jitsu.
We have get down's baby kit.
We have kit down
in two minutes.
If you guys,
there's no take down in two minutes,
we get them down then see illegal.
These kidneys tracks were illegal.
They're not illegal anymore.
They should do more of those.
When a guy has someone's back,
remember how hits him.
He used to do that to the stomach.
Why don't they do that?
That opens up the neck.
People forget about it.
You don't need to think about too.
It's true.
Totally because those are some
serious kicks to the stomach.
You're breathing,
but he does it.
They never did create some
space in Merrick county,
so strong wrestling mascot.
He had a flying Kung Fu here.
This guy's too greasy and his guy.
Oh triangle.
Oh,
you had it for a second.
He's trying.
He's trying to throw
some shit up there it is.
So receives throwing some shit up.
Kevin has who's corner?
I'm going to.
Connie's must be,
Huh?
Yeah.
100% but of course.
But how's your boy Dan harder.
You still talk to him?
Eddie,
you in touch with him at all?
I haven't talked to him in a while,
but he seems to be doing
great as a commentator.
Yeah,
he's doing great.
He's really good at it.
He's a,
he's got a book out too.
What does it say?
Like half reptile or something like that.
50% reptile.
I forget what it's mixed martial arts on.
Conspiracy theories is life.
It's got to go for a triangle right here
and he's got a fucking madame theories.
Part reptile part reptiles.
It's about his life story.
So UFC,
MMA in me,
part rep talk and I feel like
it's a bad name for a book.
I don't know.
Maybe he's got personalization for it.
Lizard man.
This is a,
this is a terrible
position for Jason Knight.
Just starts losing.
Honey is not doing Jack Shit.
It doesn't matter,
but Jason Wright is
threatening off of his back.
Oh,
there we go.
Jamie gets,
call it the crack head.
That's actually quite New
York crack head right there.
Like what is our mayor
county going to do here?
He's trying to stack them and just
pressure through and just survive here.
Look at him talking shit like that.
He's not doing anything this way.
You guys want it though?
Yeah,
I want to last.
I want to say one thing to stand it up.
Oh.
Oh
right.
When we were talking about Mark Goddard,
how Jesus was complaining was going,
dude,
he's not doing shit.
He wasn't doing shit.
That is true.
Jesus Christ.
How dare you stand them up for action.
How dare you.
There's action on the ground.
Well,
I like this action.
Oh,
he's stunned him.
He's done them.
Oh Man.
Connie,
please could take him down and while
he wants some points while he's getting
them,
I mean that's a,
that's literally always been
able to do in this fight.
Other than that,
a couple of jabs,
he landed in the first round.
True.
And I've beaten him.
Stand up.
Oh,
I was calling for a leg lock.
That's a tough sell.
He's got to do something.
Yeah,
losing this now.
Oh Dude,
for sure.
In this fight.
But it's weird.
He's losing a fight.
But what the fuck is con uh,
I'm here.
Connie done taking them down.
But that's it.
Is that enough?
Is just being on top of it
enough when the guy on top,
but he did get the tape
you got to take down.
But it's not good enough.
It's not.
It is in our common sport.
But how much of this should be scored
with Jason Knight controlling off of his
back and going for
submissions versus I'm here.
Connie literally here doing nothing.
Zero.
But he has control.
Top control.
Right.
But,
but also anybody's control though.
He's just on top.
He doesn't have any control,
but he's not doing anything
but holding him in the spot.
But Jason,
nice thought landing and he's not trying.
He's at least trying to be offensive
off of his back and Mayor Connie's
literally doing nothing.
Like all he's doing is holding on here.
Look,
that's what you guys wanted.
But Hey,
that's part of the sport.
There's plans a shot there.
He lands a shot that's good for him.
That's good for him.
But Jason Knight is being way more active.
Amir.
Connie throwing a few shots there.
Asked.
Yeah.
Now he passed.
Yeah,
I'm,
I'm with you man.
But there was a boy,
they score it.
Look out.
Look out for Jason Nights.
Neck.
I mean,
it kind of has this fight easily.
Ooh.
He could have a 10 for to choke you.
You remember that?
What does that fucking that step over?
Oh Shit.
Oh,
he heard them.
He heard him.
Ahmir Khan.
Never illegal needle.
Uh,
I think it was a punch.
The suspect.
I think the need was
to the body wasn't it?
Was it?
There it is.
Oh No,
mere county definitely win this fight.
I don't think he's winning 50.
What's that?
What's that technique?
God Damn,
I can't,
you're,
you've got one arm under the,
uh,
the,
the arm,
one arm over the top and
you step over with the legs.
You know that move.
Fuck her approval.
I call it 10 figure show.
I forgot the proven well
isn't a 10 finger choke?
The one when it's in the chest,
you got him in the chest and you have the
the head planted and we should call it
the 10 finger chokes.
It proved a necktie would we,
for whatever reason we
call it the 10 figures.
Well Tony De Sousa is the reason why
everybody calls it the Peruvian necktie
because he's got a pad who and there's
a Peruvian darts as well too when it,
oh there it is.
He was out out.
Huh?
I get pissed off you guys.
Ooh,
he knocked him down twice.
Yeah,
but so is it
a ten eight round?
That first draw?
It could be a draw
draw,
but he's this guy from the UK,
they'll fill out.
Oh he's not from the UK so hey,
maybe Kevin.
Nah,
I bet Jason loses the fight.
Decision could be,
could be
interesting.
Don't tell him.
What do you think?
They're probably gonna give it to me.
This is name.
I'm here.
Connie my probably give it down.
Yeah,
you got to take downs.
You know,
he didn't do anything on top,
but those take downs count.
Yeah.
Interesting.
Now is that the coal Maine,
do you remember?
That's fine.
Do you remember that guy?
That was,
I think the first gear teen master in
Nma was that little pick Kenya guy.
Do you remember him?
He used to fight and shoot
a little Brazilian guy.
His name was Antonio Nogueira.
Oh yeah.
I forget guillotine.
So many motherfuckers.
I think he was uh,
an Andrea Penna,
Doris Guy from Nova.
You young remember him?
He was a guy that if you shot in on him,
he was going to guillotine you and he
had his own special 10 finger guillotine.
He called.
I don't know exactly how he did.
You know,
everyone's got like their own little
modifications for guillotines cause you
really can't see the grip
when you get a guillotine.
The grip is actually hidden.
You really don't,
you,
it's a hard to tell what kind
of guilting you putting in.
Right.
Even with the high elbow
guillotines and Marcella,
Marcella teen,
it's,
it's hard to tell if you're holding it
like this or like this because the grip
is hidden.
Secret guillotines and the way
that pick Kango Nogueira did it,
man.
I still don't.
I still a,
I don't remember.
It was like weird little secret grip.
Did you ever get into the Pretzel Grip?
Did you,
will you a big on that,
that weird grip where the,
the,
the palm of the bottom hand is
facing outward and the palm of the,
the topics towards you.
That's a great,
that's a great grip.
If you get your hands together,
But the reason why Marcello,
instead of going here,
he goes here.
That's the difference is,
is when you go here,
you need your palms to meet.
So if,
if there's a guy here and I'm trying
to guillotine and the first thing he's
going to do is bring
up his hands like this,
right?
And he's going to defend
a guillotine like this.
So his first move is going
to be to come between your,
your hands,
right?
So if you could beat his hand,
then you're good.
And this is amazing.
But if you don't beat his hand,
beat his hand,
then the guillotine has lost.
But if he comes up and,
and blocks it like this and I
come around the back of my hand,
he still fucked.
So it's a sense of security
split decision.
I'm here,
Connie.
Interesting.
Yeah.
Does that make sense on the grip?
Yes it does.
Um,
the also to like the same
as like with a rear naked,
it's like if you could
keep that hand flat,
it's easy to slide it up in there.
Then if you got it like this where it's
harder to get in underneath the chin.
I'm not too sure about
that with the guillotine.
It's just a lot of people
do it with the Pretzel Grip.
Yeah.
But you gotta get your head,
your hands,
your hands together.
It's Huna with Marcello Garcia variation.
It doesn't matter that your
hands are going to come up.
They think they're safe,
but we're going behind our own hand.
So that's,
that's,
um,
when Marcello was fucking people
up with that on the daily,
no one can black belts.
Well,
what the fuck is going on?
I'm defending the Guillotine
and I'm still tapping.
Right.
It was the grip they given.
Who went decision?
I'm a Connie.
Yeah.
That's tough for a,
yeah.
What are you gonna do?
The Cub Swanson.
Zoe said,
okay.
That's not a good move for him.
No Cub Swanson Zone.
Another words calling out.
I don't know.
Jimmy Marijuana.
I'll say it's up to the Jimmy Manoa.
Okay.
I know we see crazy guys like this.
Uh,
what's the next fight?
Just talking about an
old story with Jimmy Man.
What did the rest of the ground
amazing Arnold Alan Verse Mads
Burno and show up the card.
Pull up the card.
Yeah,
he's probably delirious
from that uppercut.
Aljamain
he's trying to get a fight with Dominick
Cruz and he's a bad motherfucker.
Aljamain I liked how he bounced back
from that and Mariah's fight too.
He bounced back and Marla memorize.
Where's Jimmy Rivera coming up?
I think that's next week at
the mother fucking fight.
Yeah,
it is next week.
Right.
Is that next week?
Thanks all dude.
We need to fight night fight
companion for that motherfucker.
What day is that Jimmy Rivera as a mother.
Fuck,
he's a beast.
What Day is that?
Is that Saturday?
June 1st Friday night.
June 1st I'm in town.
You in town?
I'm in town.
That's to try and get weird son zeroes.
I mean sit and talk about it.
Oh yeah.
Fuck yeah,
man.
Let's do that as calen in town.
Callan's hustling right now.
Getting ready to do his special right.
Especially in July.
I'm opening in Chicago.
Ooh,
he's ready.
He's ready.
He said he's amped up best he's ever been.
That's awesome.
Your boy.
Uh,
yeah.
Hopefully you get picked
up by Netflix or showtime.
Your boy Joey Diaz last night on fire.
She's on fire right now.
I just put Jesus Christ.
Joseph still fucking around to like,
it's still like trying new shit on stage.
He was telling me that because Netflix,
some of the references he has,
they're like,
you can't say this.
You need to change this.
So he's messing with that.
Like how to hit the joke.
Still using that context.
What references are they?
Uh,
I don't want to give away.
Yeah.
Eddie,
you round next Friday.
The first June 1st,
which doing next Friday night.
So next Friday I'm in San Francisco.
It sounds Tripoli.
You should cancel it.
What's happening is
you're looking at Friday,
Jimmy Rivera versus Marlin Mariah's son.
That's going to be,
that is a good fight.
Jake Ellenberger.
Ben Saunders of the old to Solon at it.
If I didn't have that
spot in San Francisco,
I'd be cornering.
Ben,
you're doing a lot of standup,
man.
That's not a lot enough.
Like,
I see you're not like a real comedian.
Real comedians go out all the time.
I'd,
I'm like,
uh,
I'm like below an open miker.
You know what I mean?
Are you enjoying it?
I love it.
I love it that the show we did
a Friday night in the bedroom.
That was the most fun I've ever had.
Man,
that was so much fun.
Is it all just conspiracies
theories stand up?
Because I know you guys are calling
it tinfoil hat conspiracy night.
Is that just because of the podcast name?
It's,
it's um,
it's more designed to,
it's not,
you know,
there's a lot of conspiracy
theory comedy in there,
but you know,
you know,
it's not like 100%,
but you guys do fit,
you take fan questions too,
right.
So you can go hard in the paint.
Yeah.
At the end we do a question and answer
type of like a mini podcasts thing.
Yeah.
It's fun.
Friday night at the belly
room was so much fun,
man.
It was such an amazing room.
That's the truth.
Serum Room.
If your jokes are like fat,
if they have too much extra words in them,
if they're too fake,
they come off Corny,
that bedroom,
just highlight,
can feel it.
I've always liked to run my,
my material in that room
before I do anything.
Joey did his short,
uh,
I've never been in that room in the,
in the ice house.
The one,
not the Ma,
the big room they did in the small,
it's almost like the,
the room.
That's where he did it.
That room's amazing.
That's what we just done
that a couple of times.
A Joey too.
That's a great one.
It's a great room.
When I opened for Joey,
I love it because it's
probably 90% Latin and I love,
I love telling Mexican jokes.
I got so many Mexican stories.
It's just all fun.
There's no conspiracy theories going on.
And with those crowds
crowds to like 90% Latin.
Really?
No.
Last night was it?
No,
it seemed like it was one.
It's interesting like in Ontario,
Ontario's 9% Latin,
that's two hours a lot of fun.
It's a great room till levity,
a lot of leg work crushers
podcast last week.
And he said that
that because of you,
you,
he said that he was telling you that
Russian mafia story and then you said you
should do it on onstage.
And then he did it and it,
and it blew up at Russian mob story.
And then I remembered I go,
you know what Joe told me to
do that bleeding asshole story
problem with blood coming out of my ass.
So I told them what,
how I fixed it and he goes,
dude,
you got to do that on stage.
And I'm like,
no way.
At the first,
my first reaction was like,
fuck no,
I'm not going to talk about that on stage,
but I did it Friday and
it went over well too.
It's a funny story,
man.
When you told that I was howling laughing.
That's funny.
I like you say that like,
Oh,
you should do that bleeding asshole
story and people who are listening,
what the fuck is wrong with these on?
It's not just a matter of like how you
telling me the story and when you were
telling me a story,
I was cracking up.
I mean I am not a comedy Snob by
any stretch of the imagination.
I like comedy.
I like things that are funny and
if it happens to be funny for x,
Y or z reason,
I don't care.
I just want,
I like to laugh.
I like funny shit.
I just,
I don't believe that like,
like there's,
there's certain subjects
that should be off limits.
It's just a matter of how
you approach the subject.
If it's a part of life.
The problem is a lot of subjects are
tainted because a lot of people do bad
comedy that's like
cheap and easy and they,
they,
they like,
they use those subjects instead of,
because the subjects are interesting
and they have like a real valid point.
They use those subjects because they
know it's going to get a cheap laugh.
No original thought was
the Fart joke or a cheap,
you know,
whatever kind of joke.
There's,
there's a bunch of cheap jokes,
but then there's like real live situation
when you have to shit your pants,
like told her you should.
Fear had a fucking hilarious joke about,
there was a bridge across,
uh,
in Sydney.
This is crazy bridge.
It's like two miles long or something.
You walk across it and he was halfway
across the bridge and you had a shit his
pants and he told the story and he had
an agent at the time and told them,
that's a shit joke.
You gotta stop doing that joke
and already looked at him.
He goes,
yeah,
we're not going to work together anymore.
He just got rid of them.
Just get rid of his agents like get the
fuck Outta here cause he told me about
it.
I go,
what?
I go that guy I told you to stop doing
that bit cause it was a real story.
I was with him,
we worked together and Sydney,
that's what makes it fun.
I mean but it was a real
story where he had a shit,
his pants and he was a mile
into it and it was killing,
killing and his stupid ass agent was like,
you know that is a,
that's a shit joke.
Show into a shit show because he
doesn't get it because he hears when,
when people are talking about just like
why would she of the Asian on Asian
maternity,
Asian,
no agent in Asia did I?
It's early.
Why would he,
why would he
he didn't.
But when look,
here's the,
there's two stages of your career,
right?
There's a stage where other people
trying to tell you what to do.
They're like,
what do you need to do is wear a tie.
Well you need to do is change your ride.
What you need to do is go clean.
I went through all that shit too.
And then there's a stage where
they just leave you the fuck alone.
Ari is now in that leave you the fuck.
Cause he's successful
because he's successful.
When you're successful you can
say what you want to do it.
A few years back he was
in that you might make it,
you might fall apart stage in in an
agent's eyes like agents look at you and
they go,
man,
I don't know,
Eddie might be able to make it,
but you're going to have
to change some things.
It would change the way you're dressed.
Change your hair dry as all star bleeding.
Asshole thing is alienating fans,
you know,
and they,
they get it in their head that
they know how to fix your act.
They're almost always wrong.
They're almost always wrong or
he's hilarious at the same major.
He didn't tell him either one of us.
Shit already doesn't give a fuck.
Now Ari is like,
does my favorite example,
he's got a flip phone.
But he's my favorite example
of a dude who got money,
got some fame and some
wealth and got some success.
And just said,
fuck you,
I'm doing whatever I want.
Yeah.
Bird was saying like a torn was,
uh,
he was taking some time off.
He's just,
he's going somewhere now.
Like does he want a toy?
He's like,
he just needs a certain minimum
and that's all he cares about.
He hits that things out.
He made his monthly nut or as year the
[inaudible] he said in the first couple
of weeks of the year,
they just did a bunch
of theaters and some,
some good breaks.
No.
Alright.
Shit.
And he just,
he's got a fucking low overhead and man,
he doesn't have a car.
He lives cheap.
I mean,
he's just,
he keeps that way.
It's still in New York.
Yeah.
He's hilarious.
He doesn't give a fuck man.
I mean,
and he loves traveling.
He loves traveling.
He's material from it.
Right?
Well,
it's not just that man,
he just really enjoys going
to different cultures and be,
I mean,
he went to fucking Asia Dude like Asia,
Asia,
pistols and shit staying in places
where like 18 year old backpackers go.
I mean those same steps,
like your field,
that you're in danger.
He was not,
not ever,
I'm like,
what?
I'm too scared to do that.
I wouldn't want to do that.
Well,
I don't think it's dangerous.
I mean,
I think it's rarely dangerous,
but I think any kind of travel you mean?
I mean,
I'm talking about traveling to a bar
in Canoga park could be dangerous.
You know,
you hear about it in a story.
Brendan Schaub Joe Rug and go to a bar
and Canoga Joe gets stabbed by some crazy
person.
Oh,
don't go to Canoga Park.
That's not what it is.
It's just like life is
occasionally dangerous.
You know?
I don't think those hostels are most of
those hostels or just college kids that
are just traveling abroad
and looking to see the world.
I've always been scared of houses.
My brother stayed when you're up,
until he woke up.
So in sucking on his toes.
That's scary.
Well,
what?
I was scared of it because
of those horror movies,
the hostel,
the hostel.
Are We fucking terrifying?
Part Two's even more Teresa.
Dude,
how's still is so hostile is brutal.
Man.
How easy is it to,
to Lord,
you know those 18 year old
backpackers that are across Europe.
So I'll leave,
dude.
All you gotta do is get hot chicks point
out the dude's a hot chicks would drag
him into some shit,
put some,
put some drugs in that drinks and book
and two 50 year old and a 35 year old.
A hot chick.
But Ya,
yeah,
where are we going?
You asked it,
but when you're 20 when you're
21 warm hole in the wall.
No,
what I'm saying,
it's easy.
That's how they got them and hostile.
They just said they just sent
chicks straight after him.
That's the easy chicks
work every due to fall.
Right.
They'll fall right into it.
Man.
Chicks with drugs,
you know,
drink and it's over.
But I think for a lot of those people
that travel like that and live like that,
it's gotta be very hard to settle down
once you get used to just traveling to
and drugs and partying places.
And I feel like that movie
doesn't end well for those people.
There's no real stability life.
Everyone.
Everyone has their own
movie playing right now.
No,
it definitely doesn't end well.
I mean maybe start a pottery
business or some shit
like and pottery.
What does this one,
this is another movie that Eli Roth made.
He also made hostile.
It's called green inferno.
I did see this where they eat each other.
Did they get eaten by cannibals
or Brazil or somewhere?
Some
don't.
This was breezy.
It was like some remote
location like in the jungle.
I was actually a little
disappointed in this.
The trailer.
I was like,
Oh shit is the head of the
upper left hand corner.
That's some crazy shit that happens
in the movie to send me that.
Send me that a text message man to watch.
Don't you think like Brazil,
like tourism is down 8000%
because of these fucking movies.
You know what I mean?
It happens though.
Shit does happen,
but you know what still maybe Brazil
is like slow the fuck down with these
goddamn movies,
but they do have the biggest rain
forest in the world and they do.
This is scary shit.
Fucking Amazon forest.
I couldn't breathe.
I was a text Tim Kenny and I say,
I can't believe when he's
talking about all of those Nazis.
What the fuck in they flew from
Germany to fucking Argentina.
That's a true story.
I text until I went,
Dude,
you did the greatest promo ever for
your discovery and history channel show.
Cause I really was.
I love Tim,
but I don't watch that much TV with that,
with that stuff.
He was talking about those
Germans that live in Argentina.
How many cities?
How many villages?
I don't know what?
Hundreds of thousands.
100,000.
And you go to the village,
this is an rd term and it's all German.
The architecture,
we go into the house,
it's all fucking term images of a chain.
They don't speak out the
fucking lick of Spanish.
They were leader hose in that drink and
giant steins and show proud of their
history.
Yeah,
that's what's creepy about.
He goes,
you know what built that land juice.
Fucking the,
their,
their cavity fillings.
Third Wedding rings.
That's what built that in.
So what do I got so upset,
man.
And he's talking about how,
uh,
how they would torture kids.
I just heard,
I stopped listening at that.
I'm out.
Well,
he was talking about how Mengele and a
lot of the SS soldiers went to Argentina
and continued a lot of their torture
experiments and that they had met some of
the people that had been
tortured by these ss guys.
Horrific,
horrific boy.
They break their bones,
bring nurse him back to health,
set them on fire.
Just the worst shit you can imagine
just to see like what they could do.
I went to Argentina like,
like 10 years ago,
and I swear,
I swear to God,
I've never been to a country with so many
beautiful women really was on believe,
say no one there.
And it's like there's,
you see like 10 at a time,
13,
they're like everywhere.
And you would think you would think
it would be easy to pick them up,
but it's super hard because they
have no faith in men because the men,
they're like prostitution.
Schlegel yeah.
They know that there's no reason for a
guy to to get committed so they don't
trust guys.
So they're like,
just,
that was my experience that
they just like hang out.
They hang out with each other and
they just kept blocking child wiener.
They travel,
cock blocked each other.
They travel in packs,
they're everywhere.
It's incredible blessing.
They're only touching on,
I'd love to go to Argentina.
You watch this.
It's,
it's crazy man.
And it,
and Tim said you'd go there and you know,
they're,
they're like so,
so proud of their Nazi
grandfather and stuff like that.
And Tim's like,
what the fuck man,
that's crazy.
Crazy.
No,
no,
no.
Not a lick of Spanish anywhere.
And Hitler may be,
uh,
you know,
yeah,
that's,
Joe asked him,
he goes,
if you have to decide right now,
did Hitler die in that bit
on like history tells you,
and this is Tim Kennedy.
He's never told a lie in his life.
He goes,
nope,
history's wrong on this one day.
And he'd be so happy about
what that history is wrong.
History is often wrong.
That's what I'm saying is
during Kennedy approves it,
it's fucking,
we go and sizzler [inaudible] he's
never told a lie on the sizzler.
Tim Kenny's never told her line is live.
Are you sure?
No,
dude.
Tim Kenny says,
I mean he's as American pies it gets,
yeah,
I love that guy,
man.
I cried because I thought
he going to die one time.
I love him.
He doesn't have a crazy show that
he where he tries to kill himself.
They tried to kill him.
Like what's the name of that show?
Uh,
what's it called?
It's like some show where someone almost
dies goes in Atlanta and jumps out of
planes.
Yes.
Oh,
you a bull fighting hard to
hard to kill Tim Canada Ham.
That's what Steven Seagal movie,
isn't it?
Yeah,
it is terrible movie.
All those,
a fan as a kid,
but yet,
and then he also has hunting
Hitler on the history channel down.
He's a beast man.
And then he's still serving,
doing like secret missions and
killing people on the side.
His side,
chicks killing isis.
That's what he does.
What he says,
he's still active.
Special Forces going on projects and shit.
Killing people corralled.
Yeah.
Hell yeah.
Damn
dudes.
Another level.
Yeah.
Wait,
this main event man,
is it hard?
Kind of bullshit,
man.
God,
dog and fights and accident.
Well thanks for that.
So how standup gun,
it's good man.
Grinding every week.
Six spots last week it for this week.
And then folks approach
you for a special nope.
Not yet.
Not yet,
man.
He's a little ways to go.
And you've been doing
comedy now for a year?
Two years.
It's been two years.
Shit,
two years.
I've been doing live fire in
the kids for over three years.
That's where it started.
Yeah.
Damn.
I,
for some reason I thought you
were doing standup for a year.
I've been doing it.
My first spot was at the comedy store.
I have it written my phone.
I'd have to look comedy chaos night.
Uh,
no,
it was a,
it was uh,
they gave me a spot in the belly room.
Fastest rising comedian of all time.
Right.
Like,
cause with zero standup experience and
then all of a sudden you do standup and
now you're fucking playing all
over the world making loot.
Right.
It's good.
You're getting paid,
right?
Yeah.
That is almost as good.
That's incredible.
I'll never fast fall time you
could be doing to us Jews.
Generally you grind for about 10
years until you pop if you do it all,
but I think you can do like the Charlie
Sheen route where if you have some sort
of fallen,
you do shows and then people are like,
this sucks.
I don't come back.
I think the sign of it is you do,
you can come back to if you sell
tickets of places you've been before.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
So it's not so they
know it's not a gimmick.
That's the big thing.
Yeah.
That's I'm doing,
which I can learn either way.
It's incredible.
Congratulations.
That's saw the fuck didn't I didn't,
I was hanging out with Joe
in the comedy scene for many,
many years.
I seen comedians just eat shit,
you know?
Can we crash?
Yeah.
Come and go.
Never make it.
This same guys from 15 years ago
still trying to make it say material.
What you're doing is incredible,
man.
It's like,
it's unheard of.
Thanks man.
Sam was telling me you were
killing it the other night.
I had a good set Friday night.
Yeah.
It came together.
It was a,
it was the first set I did not stoned.
That's good.
So I decided,
you know what,
unless you're really good at something,
you shouldn't be smoking
weed and doing it.
You know what I mean?
And until you are super confident
and you got your shit down,
don't smoke week,
you know what I mean?
So I decided to try it out,
like not smoke weed and go on stage
and see what happens and earn.
It went good.
It went,
it went better than,
that was probably my best set.
So,
and then you guys are at cobb's on Friday.
Friday at cobb's has never,
never been there.
A bunch with Joe.
Love Calkins day the best.
You've been there a couple of times.
Uh,
twice now.
Headline.
Yeah.
Fuck.
Twice down.
Then I'll be back.
He sell it out.
Yeah.
Holy Shit.
That's a 300 400 seats.
Yeah.
God Damn Dude.
Holy Shit.
Then we do a Saturday,
we do Sacramento,
the punchline.
So that's a smaller,
that's like 150 to one
or something like that.
Uh,
but uh,
yeah cause can San Fran to,
until I get my shit together,
you know,
I'm going to go on stage,
uh,
clear-eyed or this the smartest route man.
And then later,
once I,
once I feel super
confident in my material,
um,
and we have right now,
my problem is I have way too much material
and it's just scattered everywhere.
All these ideas,
every day I have new ideas,
but they need to be organized
more and fleshed out.
And that's what I did for,
for this show too.
I decided,
you know what,
there's just so much
and it's overwhelming.
I just took three pieces,
pull my goal.
I'm just going to stick to these three.
Yeah,
exactly,
exactly.
And um,
have as great at helping with that too.
At first I was writing
everything out and then I,
then Joe,
he told me,
he goes,
dude,
you're,
you're at your best when you don't write
it out and you just go off the cuff.
So Joe,
he told me,
just have ideas but don't write anything
out and just go out there and try it.
And I,
and I did that and I
think that's for me that,
you know,
Friday I just had powerpoints
and a couple of lines like,
okay,
this line is kind of funny in
that line is kind of funny.
And then I just went off and
just kind of just went for it.
It worked out great.
It worked out.
I doing a ice house last
night with Sam and said,
I want to go.
Oh cool,
cool.
You guys write your material out,
write material.
Well you know what,
because hanging out with you for
fucking 20 years in the comedy clubs,
you,
we stress,
you got to write shit out.
You got to Russia,
you tell every company,
right?
Yah.
So that's what I was doing.
I was writing everything out and a Joe,
he told me,
he goes right now,
maybe you shouldn't write shit out.
Just go out there and just free ball,
just have some ideas.
And I said,
are you sure?
And he said,
yeah.
So I did a couple of
spots with them at the,
uh,
Ontario Improv.
And those are,
those are two of the best
shows I've done with Joey.
So I decided to do that.
Just have instead of write everything out,
maybe write out the funny,
you know what I mean,
but just kind of go out there
and repealing the same set over,
doing new set to retire
every sets mixed up.
Different
bullet points or like what's like say
if you had a bid on building a table,
whatever.
Like it's the bullet points,
the funny parts you have memorized.
Yeah.
The line like memorize the fund
and then the way you set it up,
you're going to have to kind of,
I kinda just go for it
cause it's more natural.
Exactly.
Cause if you start memorizing shit,
um,
it takes away from the spontaneity.
Yeah.
It just doesn't,
it's not funny.
You can find it in there though.
The spontaneity.
Even though you have a
structure you can play with.
The one thing,
the one thing that I've
learned for me anyways,
like I watch,
I still watch Chapelle over and over
and just like you know it for me,
like the,
the latest Chappelle when he tells a story
and he's telling you like a 10 minute
story of how shit went down.
To me that's the funniest.
She had an actual real event,
like the mafia story,
the Russian mafia story
with Bert Kreischer.
Yeah,
it's an actual story,
right.
Then you see how real it is when he's
describing it instead of trying to make up
a joke and trying to find funny,
stick to funny stories and then that'll,
and then from there you could kind of,
you don't know,
you know Joe's shooting mine on Monday
night in Vegas and the shooting six of
them,
not just six.
So there's six comics,
30 minute specials,
but big j auctions in that.
Who's hilarious?
Christina P.
Thompson Arrows wife's is in that.
She's doing that because
she just didn't know.
I wonder why.
Just blowing the fuck up.
I know,
but why not just shave it and do an
hour trying to extra bloat that bank,
I love her at that extra blow up.
But with Joe.
Yeah,
Joey's,
yeah.
And then they shoot to 30 minutes for him.
He shoots on Monday night in Vegas,
Sun Room in Vegas.
But when you do those 30 minutes,
cause I,
you know,
I'm used to dealing with you and I'm like,
oh.
And you're like,
I'm gonna shoot it here.
This is what's happening.
And there's,
you know,
you have say in marketing with that,
it's different that can
shoot in here selling.
He's going to be,
this is where the time different animal.
Yeah.
It's a different animal for sure.
Brendan selling out COBB's
in San Francisco by himself.
Holy Shit.
That's fucking huge man.
So that consumer in Boston,
the what?
The Wilbur Theater and house
and it's 1100 somethings.
Oh Shit.
God Damn.
I told him he's,
he's probably one of the fastest rising
comics coming from never doing standup.
I mean,
who else is there really ever,
ever.
Right low ever for sure.
That's what I'm telling stand up to
selling out theaters in two years.
Did you know this?
I mean,
it's incredible.
It's incredible.
Doing like fucking an
hour and killing like you,
you put in the work,
dude.
That's what I tell other young comics.
I say pay attention to him because this
is what happens when a person takes pro
athlete type of discipline
and applies it to stand out.
That discipline is everything
that work ethic and discipline,
that's everything mad.
It changes the whole game because
a lot of comics are funny,
but they're fucking lazy.
They're fucking lazy and they don't they,
that's why I like you.
You're dealing with guys who do the same
material year after year after year and
they never do specials.
There's a bunch of those guys that are
really talented guys and they just never,
they never bothered to record anything
cause they don't want to have to,
right.
They don't have to rewrite.
It doesn't make sense to me like it.
We'd talk about work
ethic and stuff like that.
I see these other comedians
who maybe aren't doing it,
but like,
don't you see the guys like
Rogan and burn deleah like,
do you want to be on there?
You want to do what they do,
right?
Oh,
he's got a guillotine.
Nasty.
It's the same with fighting.
Just like you look at GSP,
it's like he's doing this and this.
Don't you want to be like that?
She'll probably follow that plan.
But people got scared mass.
But here's the thing,
you get scared and then
you finally get some tools,
right?
Like say if you have an act like
you put together an act and you're,
you're like,
before we ready to film a special,
the idea is that your act is killing,
right?
So if your act as killing,
you've got molden at home.
He didn't want to let that go.
Like I got to let it go.
Oh,
I can't wait.
Decide,
go.
I gotta
take it aside.
But if you don't do that,
you don't keep getting better.
But here's the thing.
One thing that I've learned,
even though there was a lot of fear
in letting go that old material,
you always write new,
better material because
you're a better comedian now.
You understand comedy better.
Yes.
You're just going to do better.
Like for me,
like letting go that like
Bruce Jenner bit God,
it was so hard to let go.
I didn't want to let that one
go because of the special.
Yeah,
no,
but I couldn't,
I couldn't do that if
my life depended on it.
Right now I don't know how it works.
I don't know the beats and
I wouldn't do it right.
But when you get to a point when you
get a bit so tight and so finely tuned,
that's when you got to let it go and
then you move on to the next one.
And I've got some shit now that that's
killing harder than that bit did.
But when I first started doing,
you know,
a year ago,
year plus ago when I first released that
Netflix special and then I went right
into write new material and doing
new material is on shaky legs mat.
And a lot of people don't
like that shaky legs feeling.
You get real scared,
but you got to go through that.
You've got to go through that.
And that's what makes you grow
and continue to get better.
But you know,
one of the things that helps me a lot
that a Jeremiah Watkins show that stand up
on the spot,
dude that is a fucking farm for material.
So much fun because people yell
like someone look at you and go
of of hurricanes and you
lay man hurricanes and then
you start talking chin.
Every now and then they'll say something.
It has a bar and the crowd,
the crowd knows like you don't,
you just riff and they're not looking,
you know,
they know you're not shooting special.
Everyone's pretty loosey Goosey
and they'll yell like strippers.
I'm like that about them.
Yeah,
it's amazing dude.
It's an amazing resource to have
those shows where someone just yelled,
he used to call it Thunderpussy.
They used to do it in the,
uh,
the ice house to the sun.
It was easy.
Great name for it.
So intense.
Just so sales get up on the spot.
But,
uh,
yeah,
I've been doing that show for years.
That's helped me a lot.
It's a lot of,
and I told Jeremiah,
you were telling me how you got bits
from it and it's the same thing with
fighting.
Like if we had a training room,
you know how this is,
well if you guys know this,
there's one guy who's fucking these
really good and you know maybe tapped out
last time.
He kinda,
you don't mean to you avoid him because
he was going to be the tub surrounding.
Like I'll just go over here.
That's how I was with
Jeremiah on stamp on the spot.
I was like,
man,
I know my stuff.
I write all my stuff,
I know what I want to do here
and I can have fun with that.
But on the spot,
I dunno,
man kept canceling on him.
He would text me like this week I'm like,
yeah,
for sure.
Then the next day like dude,
I'm swamped them
and then I told them,
hey,
next time you asked me to do it,
no I'm lying to you.
I need to do this cause I'm scared of it.
What's the show called?
Stand up on the spot.
Jeremiah Watkins belly around.
I think there's a show that night.
Every Tuesday night.
Tuesday night.
Stand up on the spot.
Yeah.
No,
not every Tuesday night.
Every Tuesday night.
Yeah,
that's why I'm saying I think it's
this Tuesday by way I would try that.
Am I?
Am I going crazy?
I thought he said cause
I was to do three spots
in the night and I go,
hey,
you have to with a spontaneous no,
cause I went last Friday,
calmed me stone and stone another spot.
I don't think it's until June.
Honestly.
I think he just did it and I was out
of town and I was on his last one.
When was that?
How long ago?
Two weeks ago.
Yeah.
So the next one would be like two weeks.
All right,
that sounds like fun.
Oh it's the best.
June 12th June 12th there you go.
Tuesday,
June 12th
I fucking love it man.
It's,
it's really fun and
it's always packed too.
Yeah,
it's packed.
And again,
the crowd knows what's going on.
Did that for a while after your shows?
He would do like question and
answer and there was nothing,
there was nothing.
Anybody could have yelled out that
you couldn't tie into some pass bit.
You know what I mean?
You had,
there wasn't anything.
Yeah,
it's better though.
The standup on the spot thing is better
because it's not that it's not past
bits,
it's all just can't do
material if you know,
they tell you no,
no material.
It's gotta be why people have done
it and done their act two and Pete,
the crowd gets mad.
They know they can,
they know what's up
cause you know it's not,
you can tell what's off the top and went,
yeah,
yeah.
Do you remember when we
did fan Q and a at Wilbert?
So I did my show and then we'll,
you know,
Boston,
it was late and you know,
the dudes were drunk.
I kept flying.
Heckler
fucking went nuclear on.
The guy's like,
it's typically isn't how my fake
questions go and fucking get a scarf on
fire.
All right,
well that's it for big questions.
Where'd it go?
Fuck face.
Well,
he was just,
just trying so hard to get attention.
I've witnessed many,
many people getting torched by Joe once.
It's,
it's,
it's awesome.
It's awesome.
It's awesome watching Joe because Joe,
he doesn't want to
release until the guide.
It's clear 100% and he deserves it.
So a guy will yell and he's like,
calm down everything and he's like,
and like inside,
like keep going.
So I could just feel guilty.
So when Joe Decides to go off,
it's over son.
There's no way I dealt with a mic.
Forget Joe without a Mike.
You're still fuck dude.
I saw dank to go hard on these
two girls in the front row when,
uh,
when I was at the comm
store last Tuesday night,
oh my God,
they wouldn't quit talking.
And he's like,
honey,
you're trying to get through a story.
And he was a longer story.
You could tell he's doing new material.
He's trying to get through it.
They kept interrupting.
He's like,
well,
I can go in on you if you want.
Say another thing.
And she's goes,
another thing goes,
do you want to do this?
And then just fucking cuckoo.
Cuckoo,
cuckoo.
I mean it was just brutal,
man.
It makes a show though,
cause he did about 20 minutes of it.
There's a lot of fucking heckling
in at the comedy store lately.
People want to become a part of the show.
That's a terrible idea.
They should be a warning warning.
Oh there's two girls in the front row
the other night just drunk and sloppy and
talking really loud.
You know,
like you're onstage and you hear them.
He tried to ignore them,
but then you see the
rest of the crowd going like this.
That's when you have to acknowledge it.
You have to see people
turning towards him.
You're like,
all right,
I got to play copier most of the time.
The stores on top of that,
which is a new thing in the old days.
Yeah.
The way I got good at
heckling at hecklers,
one of the big ways is there was
no crowd control at the store.
I mean Zero Mad Max because in the
old days when I used to go there,
the fucking comedians
were all doorman and,
and uh,
security.
Everything was all comedians.
It's not that anymore.
Now they have like legit security,
like big guys.
They take care of everything
people have earpieces on.
They're in control of everything.
When the store picked up the business
like about three years ago when it really
took off three,
four years ago,
that's when they'd go,
okay look,
this place is sold out
every fucking night.
And then a guy got murdered there.
There was a murder on the front porch.
Yeah,
Guy got shot to death on the front porch.
it was some gang related type thing.
Some guy did something to somebody and
apparently that dude who got killed,
he had some really dark
shit on his Facebook to like
pictures of people tied up
and shit and uh,
they murdered him.
They shot him right in the front porch
and from then on they put like a super
intense security system
there and cameras everywhere.
Hired real security everywhere
and ramped up the place.
Stop letting people walk
into the parking lot.
That was a big one too,
because people would just stroll into
the parking lot and these drunks,
people would be backing up their cars
and people would be getting hit by
people's cars.
A shit show.
What is the Shit Shit.
Do you think's going to happen to the
comedy store now that Mitsis passed away?
Do you think that DePaul is,
the business is better than ever?
The thing about it is it's sold out every
night and it's making a lot of money.
Like if you go to the comedy
store on a Tuesday night,
you're going to have a sold out main room.
400 people sold out.
Oh,
our hundred and 70 people
sold out belly room 80 people.
I mean that is big money,
but every night to two shows a night off,
that doesn't say two,
two main room shows every night are both
sold out now thousands and thousands of
people funneling into that place.
As far as like from the beginning of
the shows that started at eight o'clock
till two o'clock in the morning,
people are buying drinks.
It's make money isn't enough
money to keep it running back.
Yes,
it's very profitable.
It making more money now than
in the history of the club.
Never made more money ever.
So it's a viable,
I mean it's crazy.
It's all within the last
three and a half years.
Three and a half since you've been back.
Yeah.
It all just boom.
It took off.
This podcast blew it up.
Yup.
Singlehandedly you come and part
of it and they don't deny it.
I talked to management there.
They don't deny it.
I asked him like,
what?
You know,
what do you,
what do you think is the cause of this?
Boom?
He said Joe Rogan.
They'll say Joe rogue.
Huge part of it.
And then you have all the
comics coming through.
It's the golden age of comedy,
right?
Yeah.
It's also the talent there.
There's so much talent there.
It's crazy how good those shows are.
I mean you look at the
lineup sometime you're like,
what the fuck did I ran?
I ran over cause Patton
Oswalt's doing standup again.
I've ran
over to see him cause he's the,
he's there for the whole week and usually
he's a New York comic who's just up at
the or when we can Tom PAP,
honestly in New York comic,
what you mean?
Yeah,
no,
I know,
but he was in New York for a
while when he was doing stuff,
starting to stand up.
I only saw him post them
out in New York as it got.
I can't wait for him to come back
and started doing it again and again.
Yeah,
I saw him doing spots in New York a lot.
Interesting.
Yeah.
And that's on back here.
He's a good guy,
man.
Yeah.
When Tom Papa Patton Oswald
then Brogan than delete.
I mean nuts.
Top top five guys at the comedy store
right now that are regulars with Joey for
sure.
Um,
burrs there all the time.
Delay is there all the time.
Theo van is a motherfucking monster.
He's there all the time.
Uh,
who else?
Who else would you go with?
Uh,
Hinchcliffe Spin Santina was a monster.
Santina was a monster.
Monster.
Christina's a monster.
A Bert Kreischer the time.
Man,
this is so many.
There's so many.
Yeah,
there's soap.
Tom Pop out.
There's so many.
Um,
Neil Brennan,
they're there.
It's a fucking,
it's a crazy place right now.
It's crazy.
Insane.
Bobby Lee.
I mean it's just killer after killer.
I mean,
I was walking by the Eliza Lessinger,
Whitney Cummings walking by the or the,
or the other night and it was
just roars coming out of there.
And I was like,
this place is nuts.
And then you go down the hallway and
there's roars coming out of the main room.
You grew up stairs.
That's crazy.
The greatest time ever for stand up.
Greatest time ever.
You go in there and you just
feel it man in the walls.
I don't know what it is.
And then you go over to the laugh
factory and it's like an antique shop.
That's what Theo Vaughn says.
When you feel like in an antique shop.
Oh,
it,
oh my God.
You can't say that.
Yeah,
you can.
Yo.
And when they started filming people,
everybody was like,
what?
They started filming.
People just put it up on Youtube.
They say they're not doing it anymore.
But everybody just lost
all faith in that place.
They're like,
yeah,
I still do spots.
Got Two spots where I can,
but they're not releasing my shit.
The fact that they would do that,
it's like you guys are fucking mind and
then offering people half of the revenue
for Youtube.
Yeah,
just pull it up myself.
It just,
it's what,
what age are you living in?
And then when confronted,
they're like,
well,
Tiffany hydros was making so much
money now and it's all because of this.
Oh yeah,
that's delusional.
I don't know what he did.
The guy who owns it,
I don't know why he did like letting those
kids do that and put those things up,
but people that had no idea about the
standup comedy business that I basically
interns just filming people sets and
putting all their material online.
But the way it works is,
you know,
it's a close community,
so if Joe or whoever San te Santana goes,
hey,
they're film and don't
do it there anymore.
I mean it just don't,
everyone has those towns.
They go there,
demean you'll,
you'll have three sold out shows,
not even a half a mile
away at the comedy store.
And then these,
they're canceling show
cause there's no one there,
but that's a lot.
But then the Improv,
the improv still doing
the Improv's doing better.
Yeah.
And you know what,
the Improv move that stupid
fucking piano off the stage.
They put a platform on the side and push
the pan over to the piano would fuck up
the whole show for anybody that
was on the right side of the stage.
They can't see it.
He cannot see the ice
icehouse still bumping.
Right.
Bumping.
Yeah.
Especially when good comics are there.
You know,
with the ice house,
it's all about,
they have to have good people to get
out to Pasadena because the ice house,
they've had sketchy lineups in the past.
Like,
you know,
they'll have Joey and Brendan don't have
like real shows that are really funny
but to also have like some
bullshit and they had a,
for years they had some bullshit
which kills you because you get,
if you get known as that where it's
like the gimmicky bullshit guys,
people aren't going to
go on a Friday night.
Let's just go see who's
playing at the ice house.
Yeah.
Like fuck that man.
People will go down there and they'll,
they'll expect to see like a Joey Diaz
show and then some whack ass fucking road
guy who does the cruise ships more
for the people that live in that area.
Like,
I mean isn't it like
a local kind of thing?
Yeah,
but it's still,
if it's a bad show,
it's a bad show.
They don't want to come back.
See if it's a good show.
Like they know when I do,
I do those Wednesday nights,
once a month there and they
know if you go down there,
I'm going to have killers on that show.
You decide who goes on?
Yeah,
it's all my show.
It's your show.
Yeah.
Wednesday nights.
I do one Thursday night at the comedy
store every month and I do one Wednesday
night at the,
uh,
at the ice house.
Is it called Joe and friends?
Yeah,
Joe Rogan and friends.
And the next one at the comedy
store is June 21st June 21st yeah.
And just in the green room,
we're like last time it was Tony Feo,
you meet just hanging out back,
kind of like the best time I had been
out to two in the morning and we just
laugh.
It's the best man.
Those guys made me laugh so hard.
All you guys,
well it's just,
it's hard.
It's hard to find groups of
people that are just savages,
just loose and fun and ridiculous.
And then there,
this is the world they live in.
They live in this comedy worlds that
traveling around a lot fucking around
having a good time,
shit.
And one person to say something
that it's just like cool.
It was fucking on.
So that fun man,
Fun Times.
Everyone's baked.
It's just,
no,
it's just like high school
with your good friends.
Like when you walk into like
first period and all your boys,
like we hit the front.
That's what it feels like.
What a lot of ways,
right?
Because one of the things
that happens as you get older,
as you lose all the fun cause you have,
you have responsibilities,
you have a job you hate and you got to
get up in the morning and you're always
tired.
And this is the,
the world that most people live in.
When you could find a place where it's
all basically people that avoided that
rat race and figured out some
sneaky way through the system.
And that sneaky way is talking shit
to no,
no sound check needed.
You know,
you just get on stage and it's uh,
you know,
especially when high
level comedians go up,
like yourself,
like you're going to get an hour of just
laughs just over and over again.
It's way better than a funny movie.
Yeah.
But if,
if you're a new comic,
you can,
I'm getting education to,
yeah,
there's a little bit of that.
I can go in and get something
around with those people.
I can go listen to a deal.
Tell you about something that me and
Joe talked business and I'll go watch
Patton Oswald,
do his set and then I'll watch Joey
Diaz and then bill burrs coming in.
And for me,
as long as I've been doing comedy,
I still love it.
I still love watching it.
I still have watching it.
If someone's killing,
I still love it.
You know,
I love it.
It's the,
it's just,
it's a great form of entertainment and
I think it's necessary to cause people
get so serious about certain subjects.
If someone could just come along and
mock it and laugh at it so hard and then
you realize like,
oh,
this is fucking ridiculous.
This is ridiculous.
And it alleviates pressure.
What was fascinating to me the other
night with Tom Papa a Oswald and Tony
Hinchcliffe,
they all had the same
premises on their joke,
but everything was,
each opinion was so different.
I was laughing so hard man.
But you just see how
everyone is different.
But it's the popular subjects.
So like Trump,
no,
like sexual assault.
And it was so funny,
man.
I like Joe.
Is that I don't want to give away and
he's got a great back bid on that Neil
Magni it's tough to take down,
Huh?
Very death,
right?
Very wirey long.
And who's this gentleman
that he's fighting?
James James White.
Do you know anything
about Craig Craig White?
It was supposed to be a,
Oh,
why am I drawing a blank?
What's homeboys Gunnar Nelson.
Jesus Christ.
What happened at gunner?
He got injured.
I'm not sure,
but I was going to be a hell of a fight.
Yo Matt.
Neat.
Neil's beat some tough guys
speak Delvin Kelvin Gaslin.
Yeah.
Beat Kelvin [inaudible] Hendricks.
He beat Hector Lombard
injury that required surgery.
Hector Lombard Kelvin gas lunch
on Hendrix and Johnny Hendricks.
Correct.
It's pretty tough.
But then whenever he finds the there,
now whenever he fights
a Jitsu guys screwed.
It's his Achilles heel
because they take them down.
Merch umum his Jiu Jitsu is not that good.
His defense has just,
you know,
but when I say it's as
a kid is heal the only,
the,
the very tip of the spear of black belts,
fuck them up.
That's why I was so impressed with
a Dosantos dos Angeles smashed Neal.
He leg kicked him,
dragged him to the ground and
choked the fuck out of Damien.
Maia did that.
That other homeboy got
a inverted triangle.
The Bald Guy,
I forget his name.
Who is ridiculous at Jiu
Jitsu Brazilian bald guy.
Bald Brazilian advertise all Brazilian.
Tiago Alvarez.
No,
no,
no.
Oh yeah,
that guy is really good.
You put,
I guess I'll jump.
Mariah's are black and
then Damien Maia was like,
you do what?
And he's got a,
he a triangled someone from the mount
out years ago and I'll never fed BDO.
Forgot his name because that,
yeah,
he's a beast man.
He set it up beautifully.
He's got a crazy tricep too.
He's like missing a tricep.
Like you look at one of his arms
like is tricep was nonexistent.
It must've broke off and slid up for,
yeah,
it must a tour and they
never got a fruit roll up.
Yeah,
he never got it fixed
cause he's got a a Bicep,
but then there's nothing behind it.
It's very weird looking
at one of his arms.
He do.
If he's still fighting,
just got killed.
Somebody so many good.
Pull up a surgeon,
Mariah.
Hmm.
Yeah.
He was the first guy to
tap crone as a black belt.
It was like a wonder that Magni
and amount magni in the mouth.
Yes,
he has left bought tricep
is like kind of missing.
It's even weirder when you see it.
Uh,
like hanging low.
You weird there.
Pull up his,
uh,
his record.
The shit he's going for
an arm triangle here.
Immediately.
Risk Cape.
Oh Shit.
He's going to stand up.
Let me see.
Is there we go.
No,
no,
no.
It's just go.
Go to his record though.
Yeah,
that's right here.
Where's it?
Scroll down.
No,
no fights.
10 means [inaudible].
Oh yeah.
It's only k.
Oh really?
Yeah.
This one has a lot of decisions,
man.
Mm.
Super disappointed in that standup.
Matt Serra was going off about,
angry about us,
the referee standing them,
separating them.
When a Damien Maia had
his bag was ridiculous.
It was really a god who is the rough,
I want to say it was Leon Roberts,
wasn't it?
Yeah,
I think so.
It was a terrible decisions.
They're getting too
crazy with the standups.
Too crazy with it that they need a,
they need to relax.
Well,
especially in that situation,
you've got a guy who's a strangulation
expert that finally gets to clench on a
world class wrestler,
especially in those early,
in the first round,
early in the first round.
Got a real good position and I'm,
and you also have to think,
Maya took this fight with zero great camp.
Oh Shit.
And He,
Neil,
they should ask Neil
Neil's whooping his death.
He's hurt.
Come on.
You know we need them right in the face.
Yeah,
you did.
Because there's legal.
Yeah,
for sure.
Illegal.
Oh,
he's,
oh,
he's out.
He's out types it and Neil
Neil Madras round baby.
Big winning.
He'll magni.
No.
Magni stopping motherfuckers
powerful back on Neil.
Yeah,
he's a long dude.
Huh?
That's about as long as it
gets for one seventh grade.
Cardio Long.
Yeah.
And good fight Iq,
you know,
like would never blows his wad.
He's always in there like,
look at that.
Just finished the guys
barely breathing heavy.
Be seriously man.
That dude is in fucking shape.
He's always been that way,
man.
Is that just a discipline thing?
Just always trained military guy.
Yeah.
Also a Denver thing,
right?
Oh,
isn't that high?
I was in Chicago at the same
fucking cardio because I was,
I was one of the coaches on the ultimate
fighter 14 he came off that season.
Even then they're like,
dude,
look at the cardio on Neal.
What does he do for Cardio?
You know him well,
but he just training nonstop,
but was like eight mark heart when he
first came in Denver and he just kept,
you know,
Nate train nonstop.
So he just kind of took on that role.
You just trained snakes?
Don retired.
Yes.
It's done.
That's good.
Just doing the Lord's work now.
Oh,
what kind of work is that?
I do whatever the Lord wants him to do.
It wasn't worth saying,
I think a sell bibles.
I don't know what they do.
So he's working for a church or something?
I think so.
We just kept trying to become a
priest or something like that.
He was always super religious.
Always.
Yeah.
I'm glad he's retired,
right guy.
He had a lot of great fights,
man.
A lot of great fights.
One of the greats,
the great,
his Kao of Tyron Woodley for the
Strikeforce welterweight champion.
One of the all time highlight
reel candle combat Kale.
Yeah.
Literally Combo elbows the best.
I loved the elbows and opera cuts.
Son.
He's so good at,
I'm tough.
Yeah,
man.
For sure.
He uh,
he's a guy that kind of like was real
active and like real proficient before
anybody knew anything about MMA.
He started when he was 17.
Joey Joey's,
he called me a couple of times.
Should I answer the
phone and call him back?
Listen.
Cocksucker
okay.
Made her watch that Derek till
Darrin tells over there eating
pop tarts and weighs 500 pounds.
He's talking about Mckenzie
turns ass last night again.
He's terrible about that job.
What do you think happens?
What do you think that's,
what do you think happened?
You think she's just eating all the time.
Fuck the time.
I don't know Joey.
I don't know what Percy
Miss Weight by seven pounds.
She's fucking smoking though,
right?
Yeah.
Then she's very attractive.
Girl.
Joey's right now in the middle of bonding.
It's a can't answer that phone.
He'll answer.
Hmm?
Really?
Yeah.
I'm surprised that's not there.
He's calling me.
Oh,
there it is.
That's calling you back.
Where you been dog.
What does the speaker how many
times I of the call your dog.
We're on.
We're on Jre la fight companion live.
What's up?
You watch
time to watch people kick each other.
You're on the air.
You're on speaker phone.
Just what?
What are you doing?
Show cops.
Cops is a this Friday in San Francisco.
One day this week on the show to discuss.
You'll call me Korea has a fucking,
what do you call that?
Fucking extra,
extra terrestrial fucking comic.
Marsha.
What?
Joe?
I'm over here smoking
the weed that he smoked.
You know what I'm saying?
Next week I'm going to tell a new asshole
that came out last night to see uncle
Joey.
I was dropping fucking
nego jokes on this shit.
I'm ready to go.
Dog Cryo therapy right now just
listening to dogs by pink Floyd therapy.
Then I'm going to pop up fucking podcast
and I'm doing a few spots that I have
to let these motherfuckers
know who's running things.
Beautiful
Pill against Wonderboy and
my man against the other guy.
I watch it tonight on tape.
Julie,
what time?
What time are you tapings on June 4th,
seven and 9:00 PM in Las Vegas.
We're at,
where are the,
where are they filming at downtown,
I think someplace they got.
It's a small place.
Joe was made for us.
It's like a hundred seats
less than the original room.
Nice and tight.
Really.
It's like,
it's like Providence,
Rhode Island.
When was the last time
you went to providence?
A couple years ago.
That comedy connection?
Fucking deadly.
It's deadly in that this is the
same type of layout to 50 to 40.
Are there tickets available?
Uh,
there's no tickets available.
I mean there's something for you.
You know what I'm saying?
Right.
If you,
if you show up in the helicopter,
I can't deny it.
Batmobile.
I'll go down,
show up.
I would cop to than what you'll know days.
You know what I'm saying?
You just walk in and take the fucking
mic and tell people what's time but
beautiful.
But that's it.
There's nothing available.
I can't wait for people
to see that special.
Joey's going to be fucking nuts.
I'm working hard.
I've never worked this hard in my life.
I didn't know the meaning of this.
And so I listen to you of the
tapings and the try and shit.
And now I'm just doing 28 minutes set.
So all week 28,
28,
28.
Oo,
I gotta get the,
I got to get the beginning more jazzed
up because I got to make them watch.
So I got to go out there
like a fucking medial,
you understand me?
I got to go out there and hold them
until like 14 minutes and let them,
I got the strategy.
I'm going to go out there and
fucking just go off for about 14.
Then we go to watch different
corners and then they come on.
I pick my shots.
I just picked my fucking
shots like when fucking,
uh,
Eddie's guys,
what?
That dude and he fucking
the really good striker.
I got to pick my shots in the second round
and then the third round go out there
and just fucking flip point combinations
ending with leg kicks the ted down than
the until you can't take it no more.
You know what I'm saying?
That's the strategy
right there.
I'm breaking it down to three rounds.
Joe Rogan,
you did it last night.
Joey you did last night.
The Ice House.
He said,
I told Jay,
I told rogue he set him on fire man.
Yeah,
no,
no.
I broke it down to three rounds
and I'm cutting back adding,
you know what I'm saying?
I'm cutting.
I'm looking at it like an MMA fighter.
So I'm training for a fight.
So the first 11 minutes you guys fucked
and I got to jump on your criminal shit.
Like old school retool it.
Yeah.
The whole fucking old school.
Old School veto.
The second round I'm just
picking my shots like,
like a guy,
I guess Edson Barboza he picked his shot.
He picked him apart.
He kicked him in the side.
You fucked up the Siad to gloat.
She kicks off her body.
I come out like fucking that black dude
in the 70s that's when they gave him the
bottle filled with cocaine.
Milk.
Drop some knowledge here.
Fuck.
Just don't know magic bottle.
That's right.
Same one thing that brought up
for the fight against out though.
Right?
That's the same one that gave
fucking Todd ever gets out though.
Don't tell me.
I know the characteristics
of that fucking know.
You pick your dealing with in the third
round we come out like fucking all my
bride was that trainer's name.
Is that a manual?
I'm Joe Rogan.
We're watching it right now.
Jamie just put her Alexis Arguayo,
Alexis Aguayo,
Aaron Pryor,
Panama Lewis.
I don't know.
My one was getting the bottle
would be original shit.
Yeah,
it should know reactor
was sending up and shit.
Yeah,
he gave me tell him some coconut water.
You rainbow looking back
and then Aaron Pryor came
out just throwing bombs and
fuck the Lexus Aguayo up.
That was a great fight man.
Right?
This is the way you gotta do it,
man.
Old School boxing.
Aaron Pryor,
the bottle.
So Bobby's like they get
called the bottle it.
I said,
get on the bottle that I mixed
the capture that on video.
It has a bottle.
He's like,
give him the bottle
that I'm most proud of.
It is smoke coming out of it.
I wonder what the fuck was in that thing.
Cocaine.
Damn.
He's doing work.
Look it up.
Where's know?
Get the other one.
The one that I'm mixed.
I look at it.
Okay.
There's a positive.
No,
no,
not that one.
Give me the other one.
Okay.
How fucking beautiful is that?
That's one bottle.
Got a sniff and shit.
No,
that they try to get more than,
that was the one he goes.
Give me that one.
Yeah.
Bang.
He got hurt before he got fucked up.
Alexis Aguayo had a nasty right hand man.
He was watery.
His shit wrong.
So this is not the main event,
is it?
Yeah.
This is the main event.
Can we are all right,
let's go right to,
to the fight
Joe.
And we're about to watch
[inaudible] we love you man.
Love you man.
Love you,
man.
I will see you this week,
brothers.
Thank you.
Here's Dan till,
who's better than him?
He's the best.
He love that guy.
Oh,
then Joey saying till,
I'm like,
well,
well it's kind of amazing that
he's even top 10 with one win over.
A big guy in Donald Cerrone
is really 155 pounder.
Yeah,
it's very,
it's,
it's insane that I'm picking
them to win the fight,
but I am not a fan of
how they do the ratings,
I think.
Do you think it pm that's a Fox thing.
So is he as being in a stick with it?
I don't know.
Is it foxes decide decision?
That was,
that was one of Fox's deals.
They want rankings because they didn't
think the public could understand.
You know,
who's who without the
rankings to arbitrary in the
two disagreed upon by high
level people,
it will not,
no matter how you do it,
you can never get it right.
So you might as well just
try it and just let it,
you know,
let it fly.
You've got to have rank.
This is the problem is fighters going,
wait,
he's,
he's six,
but I'm fine.
I'm not fighting six men.
I want if I were before it would,
we didn't know what Derek was.
Right.
We didn't know what I'm going to do.
What is right.
What pride did just make 'em fight.
If you,
if you trying to fight,
that will never ask you again.
They try.
This is exciting,
man.
I'm fucking pumped for this fight.
They took long enough.
I feel like we've been in,
got those old school
tie tattoos on his back.
The kind of tap in.
They do that with the fucking the tapper.
You ever seen house?
That's as old school toe
tappers temple tattoos.
Is that his girlfriend on his arm?
I think it's his older
girlfriend or his daughter at,
oh
now he probably got them Brazil.
They probably don't have
the best tattoo artists,
but remember he was
young when he got that.
Did the tattoo.
Yeah.
It looks like Charlise there you think
there's a guy out there with a tattoo of
a chick?
There's like a one night
stand like one crazy.
Nicole was the hottest chick ever.
It's probably a million guys
with the one night stand.
She sucked Dick Everything.
I mean,
instead of
putting her on my back,
respect.
Preach back girl,
his girlfriend is his girlfriend.
Here we go.
Okay.
So,
um,
that's a commitment right there,
right?
Mary heard you're into that one.
That's how scared dudes our marriage.
Look,
I'll tattoo you on my arm.
Getting married.
Marriage is too prominent.
It's too dangerous.
So many people scared of that marriage,
buddy.
Here he goes,
Darren,
till the sun.
I crowd,
man.
It's too bad.
Liverpool last yesterday.
Otherwise this place be
fucking even on more fire.
Oh goodness.
Big Moment for this kid.
Big Moment.
We're going to find out a lot of on hands,
man.
He's big.
But suppose one deployment.
Wonderboy is a tall fella.
He's an inch tall.
Wonder was not as media is he?
No,
he's not.
Wonder.
Boy's name is Wonderboy.
His is the gorilla.
Yeah,
but who named Wonderboy?
Wonderboy.
And who named the grill?
The gorilla.
See,
that's it.
That's what's important.
That's what's up.
Yeah.
To find that out.
What if you called
yourself people be like,
get off to a terrible guy yourself.
Big Brown.
It's weird.
Wait,
what's your name man?
Hell Toda Nado
well,
sitting around thinking about nicknames.
Fuck Outta here.
Says that our Dan Hardee gave
him the nickname of the gorilla.
Oh,
there you go.
That makes sense.
How long ago did he says,
well,
this says he officially accepted
it as of January 20th so man,
real recent.
Fuck,
what was his name before then?
Well,
I didn't know.
I didn't know Dan hard.
Is it gone?
I just like refer to him as the gorilla
and then three days ago he wrote with
it.
I thought this was his
name for a while now.
Well,
it's January.
We're into May.
So it's technically ma.
I mean after he beat.
But what,
how long does a man have
to keep a nickname before?
It's a legitimate bro.
It's on spoken rule.
They could decide kick.
I don't have a nickname.
You want me to notice?
I get it.
Yeah,
I'm the side.
I'm a wing man.
No,
but
we,
we lost a martial arts to ruin us.
Like the sidekick.
No girl wants to fuck
the sidekick Robbins.
If you know the real
meaning to the dentist,
the dentist also sinking
his dick sucked in the bar.
See,
the dentist is such an obscure nickname.
I think he got to leave Josh neer alone.
That's his nickname.
That's so obscure one,
you know,
but then they call Eve Edwards a
dentist at one point in time because eve
Edwards cause of Erin's iron,
right?
Yes,
yes.
He destroyed it.
Broke his whole best.
Right.
Like I'm and Riley was one of those tough,
tough journeyman.
Yeah.
Tom,
he went,
Robby Lauer made his UFC debut against
Aaron Riley and just beat the brakes off
of them.
That's another super impressive
performance by half old dos Anjos right to
Robbie Lawler fight like holy shit.
It
was an amazing fighter.
Amazing.
He's like one of the best examples of a
guy was holding himself back by staying
in a lower weight class.
He did get the belt though.
Yes he did,
but he couldn't take it anymore.
His body couldn't take it anymore.
He was so big.
I ran into him in between fights when he
was fighting 55 and he was 200 pounds.
It's just too much.
When they start declining a little bit,
cause the weight cut was fucking with him.
Then he went to 70 now
he's said nightmare.
Here we go.
Wonderboy,
how tall is Dosantos?
He's short for us.
One 70 year,
right?
I think he's five nine shorter.
You know?
See if you can find that Jamie.
I think he might even be five eight.
Yeah,
that's,
that's kind of short.
Kelvin's probably like
five ten five dollars
but Tyrons five nine
to write five nine no,
he's got five ten five
11 way Woodley Woodley.
I think he's five nine.
That's what's so impressive.
I think Woodley's five 11 five nine it
says no one's got a bigger butt donk,
donk than Woodley.
When he walks into LPS,
fuck it.
Thighs on.
That guy is an ass.
He generates so much for us.
You know,
I'm,
I'm five nine now.
I'm like,
fuck yeah,
that's a medical student.
They say fucking hide.
It's a five nine motherfucker.
You know what I mean?
How was the back feeling?
It,
it's hard to tell because I haven't been
able to train because of my knee and my
shoulder.
So when I get back,
you know,
my knee's feeling better,
I'm on the bike 30 minutes a day.
So,
um,
so I decided,
I decided,
I decided to hold off on the
shoulder surgery and decided,
yeah,
I think they want to do to you.
What can I do?
I've got to shit you got wrong in there.
The labor them rotator cuff and,
but they're saying,
you know,
I finally,
I got a second opinion yesterday and um,
they told me,
man,
unless it's hurting really bad,
just hold off on it and hold off on it.
Why?
It's just,
um,
I don't want to go into surgery again man.
Just again,
I just had knee surgery and
then shoulder surgery surgery.
I'm just trying to rehab it with,
I'm going to try to rehab it with,
uh,
you know,
like shoulder rehab exercises.
I'm going to go that route first and
if that doesn't work then I'll have
surgery.
But I decided I'm not going to
have surgery on my shoulder.
They're doing some crazy
shit down in Panama.
Panama is $25,000 though.
It's expensive.
And you know when Mel
Gibson was on your podcast,
it,
I don't know man,
I'd have it.
Is there a possibility that he was like,
you know,
he has some financial interest
in the company or something?
I don't know.
It was hard to tell.
He really wanted to do it
for doctor reared and he's
good friends with that guy.
Did he help it?
So I want to believe all that Shit's real.
I want to.
But every time there's,
there's,
you hear about stem cells,
there's a new way and they do it different
and now they're taking stem cells
from here instead of there.
Figured that shit out further.
They're all good.
They're all good,
but they keep getting better at it.
But talk to Tj because Tj had
some raving things to say,
but it'll show twice.
Actor after the Mel Gibson podcast.
Oh really?
And after he was there before
and then he went again,
he went again recently.
He said,
it's why do we have to go again?
The five star?
We go,
Ooh,
I'm scared.
Someone's gonna be some.
Yeah,
I hope that's real,
man.
They just tap gloves
and hugged each other.
Holy Shit.
There's a lot of respect.
This is the shirts.
I know.
I have no idea what's going to happen.
Isn't really have no idea
what's going to have no one,
no idea.
Literally no idea.
I'm kind of nervous.
Here we go.
Bam.
What a boy's gonna have to be smart.
A lot of footwear to south
paws and other big point.
Here we go.
Get the size of tils.
Fucking thighs.
Boy.
Their styles.
Look at their styles.
Both real loose,
but more and more Thai base with till
he's going to throw front leg round kicks.
That thing about wonder boys,
he's all light on the toes.
His trigger is insane
leg kick right away by till.
Very interesting.
I'm so curious about this fight.
She that video tool put
out of him sparring.
Just beating the shit out some day.
Yeah,
it was weird,
right?
Yeah.
Very strange.
I had her heard that good,
but he knocked them out.
Yeah.
Hurting him too.
I wouldn't post that if I was him.
Yeah.
And then,
you know,
he posted some of him getting hit too
after that because he said people are
calling him a bully that I don't like
because that means he's reading the
comments and then he's
reacting to those comments,
which means people can fuck with this guy.
If you're a young fighter,
to me,
tough men to navigate through.
Well those comments,
you got to leave them alone because
there's so many you're dealing with,
uh,
you know,
a pool of thousands and thousands of
people and who knows who they are or what
their,
those Pete yet.
But also a lot of those people
aren't happy for your success.
Ms. Brown,
their life.
So they come at you.
Of course,
especially a guy like Tim is on the rise,
you know,
or anyone in the spotlight tries
that switch kick off the front leg.
UFC might want to hire someone to
help these younger guys with that.
Well.
Just give him a little psychological
counseling on how to handle it and get a
social media expert in their tils are
going to close the distance and land that
left hand over the top.
Wonderboy is not there though.
Yeah.
One voice footwork.
It's fricking ridiculous.
Well,
this is the perfect kind of style ram
to and aggressive guy coming forward.
This is what he's used to.
I have to imagine.
That's why I took the
fight to stylistically.
It was like,
yeah,
big guy,
aggressive.
Let's do it right after the fight.
Yeah.
Even though remarried,
just be Mazda doll who he's see
wonder why he shouldn't be there.
Right.
He better get the fuck out of there.
Don't stay there.
Yeah.
He loves that leg kick,
but he's a little off balance
and he didn't recuperate.
Well,
Darren made a shift as he was going to
launch that leg kick and you put them in
a weird position where he was off balance.
I mean there's some good adjustments
going on here at both guys trying to find
the right day.
What?
Oh Shit.
God till likes the fire one.
Aleks.
That slide with the right hand forward
and then look off to the left hop.
You good?
Oh Shit.
One,
two quick.
two.
Wonderboy.
Letting them know it's still there.
Boy has that a finished.
It's still there.
It looks tilt.
Tells a little hesitant
now wait a little bit.
Now be careful like a cobra man.
Be careful.
Oh,
you're talking about dude who was
like 57 and o was a kickboxer.
Good wonder by agreement as
far as high level striking.
I can't remember the last time two
strikers are matched up this well no.
And this is five round
son who I'll take it.
Oh yeah.
Who knows what's going to
happen and that's fine.
This is interesting.
So,
so there's a high level.
I was just trying
to figure it out with the left hand.
Popped him with the left hand
is caught him at the end of it.
Not a lot of power but reached him.
He's letting until know
that he's down there.
Yup.
Snap.
He's also switching legs,
switches,
dances.
Now he's all sideways.
It's hard to find a trading partner
who's going to emulate Wonderboy.
Man.
You don't really get a real look at.
Ou want you to buy it.
He's picking his shots,
but I think he's trying to
frustrate till so till jumps in.
Makes a mistake.
Oh,
looked for it.
I don't think that landed though.
Huh?
No,
look cool though.
And I was on board.
I yelled out.
You got to get off the cage chair.
He got to get out.
Yeah.
I think for one of where
these first two rounds,
just try to frustrate till
what time is it in England right now?
There's seven hours ahead or they ate,
so it's fucking eight
o'clock it's really late.
[inaudible] eight o'clock
eight 30 at night or they see,
I see.
I think it's seven 30
it's eight hours.
That's it.
Trust me.
Yeah.
You probably know.
So it's 9:30 PM right now.
Eight 30 bro.
What time is it now?
1230 [inaudible] unless there's a couple
of different times zones and the UK.
I thought it was just one.
I have daylight savings time or so.
Yeah.
Nobody should have that shit dead.
Arizona does it right?
They do.
They like fine.
Fuck with it.
And that our sleep we lose.
Got Real.
Fuck yourself should be a two year old,
but how about when you gain that out?
Oh,
it's nice when you gain
it for like two days.
Not worth it,
bro.
It's not worth it.
Fuck my test in the morning.
It's dark in the afternoon.
It's not your boys too.
Yeah,
he's two now.
Mike six.
He's all into Harry Potter and Shit now.
That's cool.
Damn,
we got it.
We go to universal studios.
How awkward if you haven't been you,
you haven't been a universal studios.
You need to go universal studios.
Fucking brules now the
three d simulations.
Hell yeah.
High level that that Harry Potter ride.
Holy Father,
the new guards or galaxy.
It.
Disney's pretty sick.
I was straight up scared.
I was scared.
That transformer ride is amazing.
Also in the Simpsons.
Amazing land is sick.
Yeah.
Springfield,
their rides every,
you know what's the best ride ever?
All time.
Hands down.
Flights of passage.
Avatar ride in Disney world in Orlando.
Simulation.
It's incredible,
dude.
It's incredible.
It's like virtual reality.
You go in,
you sit on this bike,
you're riding a dragon.
You saw Avatar,
right?
You're riding one of those
things through the fucking junk.
It is every is think of like,
have you ever done that?
That there's the thing at Disney
land called soaring over the world.
Will you?
It's amazing.
Giant screen.
You're flying like
over India and over the Everest.
It's a made sure that
it's not Disney world.
They don't.
No,
just did it.
Just did it sister.
Yeah.
Disney world.
Disney land has soaring over the world.
Oh,
but oh,
here we go.
Round to fuck
around.
I'll remember.
Oh,
he'll get a little more aggressive.
Tagged him with that left hand.
And that castle that,
that Harry Potter Castle that they build.
Like what the fuck?
That's amazing.
Now it's incredible.
Tills getting way more amped up.
Oh Shit.
The one mistake,
man.
I know.
I wonder,
boy.
Such a good counter fighter.
Oh,
he lifts where I'd done.
Ooh.
Gotta get off the fucking fence.
That's all till once.
So that first round you got
to give it to one or more,
right?
I mean,
super close,
but yeah.
Yeah.
Give it to Wonderboy.
You have to wonder,
boy,
not a whole lot going on most.
I mean he landed like maybe two shots,
one of the body than that
one to remember this though.
They're in Liverpool,
the home kit,
he's the hometown kid and the
judges look at a octagon control,
so it's not necessarily
could give to wonder.
Boom,
that that frontline Darren until
I don't think landed anything,
but he's going forward
and the judges are morons,
so like,
oh,
going forward.
That works well.
Give it to till he did a good job.
Didn't t they always ask a
question after they say something.
He's amazing.
Isn't he
fantastic?
Righthand wasn't it
the sites route to get
loose in the third round?
I feel like what's getting loose?
Heredi a little bit.
It's just such a dangerous chess game.
I know.
And Wonderboy hands,
motherfucking down side.
He's always like that.
It's like that.
That's that karate style sign.
Ooh,
look for it till slid,
slid to the right heel tills.
Elbows are no joke either.
Now if he gets in close,
they're the one that he landed on cowboy.
It was God.
Who else has he beaten?
It's about it,
sir.
Yeah,
I'm really,
uh,
in anybody else.
He hasn't really,
he hasn't really knocked you off
your socks before that cowboy fight.
He's had some decisions.
They did.
He knock out.
You stopped somebody to know
yet early on he had one stop.
It's,
Oh shit.
Ooh.
Damn one the bar.
We left Wonderboy.
Tom.
A very smart man.
Yeah.
Well this is like,
again,
stylistically such a great fight because
this is the style that Wonderboy really
does.
Like he likes a guy that's Uber aggressive
and when it turns in terms of like
high level technique bolt,
these guys are really good.
Really,
really good.
Don't till till keeps on that front
leg side kick to the frontline.
Oh no wonder that a
little short Hixon yeah.
He doesn't like,
no wonder he's going to
have to adapt to that.
Yeah,
they both switch it up,
don't they?
Yup.
Oh ooh.
Just missed that head kick son.
But uh,
miss financial is as good as a mile.
Tills got great distance control.
They both do.
Don't they don't.
They don't.
They?
That's Irish,
isn't it?
I don't know.
My accent suck.
We need a high natto in here.
I have some scouts for us.
Amazing kids.
Definitely a different accent to,
it's the thick man.
Yeah.
Sunderland,
Liverpool thick as Liverpool
I think is Ozzy Osborne.
Oh,
Russian in man.
Why did the boy loves to do that?
Like switch blitz.
Blitz.
Yeah,
but it's,
it's so,
it's so hard to figure out what the fuck
he's going to do because he switched
his stance as well.
He does it sometimes and
then we'll throw a kick.
Yeah,
he's about to rush in again.
Tills just trying to figure out and
pin him down but it's not there.
I wonder how this is.
This is one of the boys game plan
man Kimmy commit and make a mistake.
Then she capitalized but tills doing a
good job of not giving them much space
where the cages,
this is not happening in the center
of the cage as much as it's Ha.
Oh wonderful.
I try that sweater chills going to feel
any pressure get a finish cause till is
absolutely controlling
the center of the cage.
They under boy does not have a lot.
Well now they're in the center and you,
you know that wins
rounds for these judges.
Yeah.
Cause they don't understand fighting
that place is packed too man.
Oh,
I'm sure they say you know,
he's a superstar superstar
and be the face of uh,
England man.
Big Knock out here.
It'd be the fee cause Bisbing he is,
but if he's retired,
yeah.
Who else is coming up in England?
Uh,
we got uh,
micro van and page,
right?
Sure.
Yeah,
but he's not,
he's not in this level.
Well why don't they give
him high level fights?
He just had fought a Rickles.
Do you see what he did to him?
No.
Fucked him up.
I heard he explode his
face and choked them out.
Yeah.
And that was like his first,
like they weren't feeding him,
you know,
like that was a tough fight.
Mike van page daily.
Next they say and,
and Roy MacDonald Musashi.
Ooh.
Those are two very good fights.
I really,
me,
I really like page daily cause
they don't like each other.
They fucking hate each other.
I liked that fight.
I'll watch.
Shout out to all the 10
plan of schools in the UK.
We got like a eight now.
Damn crazy lung.
10 30 lunch.
This neighborhood.
How many cranberry Redditch Darlington.
Uh,
Shit.
Am I missing one?
Oh,
glass gal.
That's Scotland.
Scotland.
How many got worldwide?
About a hundred.
That's amazing.
It's crazy.
Amazing.
Ooh.
And it keeps growing,
man.
It keeps growing.
Know he hit him with
that psychic and a niece.
See wonder boys leg.
Bucko she's out in the replay.
He didn't like that.
He hit him with three straight.
One of them really made his knee buckle.
Ma'Am.
Those things fucking so here it is.
Michael Van and Paige highlights.
We'll kick them.
Oh Shit.
Damn.
He's so fast.
That's again karate.
He comes from that point
fighting background.
You know,
there's a great karate
match that I watched.
I mean,
I don't know how many times they fought,
but on,
um,
uh,
they fought point fighting
way back in the day.
Um,
Raymond Daniels and Michael then and page
fought each other and point fighting.
Now,
Raymond Daniels is the glory champion
and Michael Van and Paige is coming up in
Beltour.
Very interesting.
Oh,
he's a belt or champion now.
Raymond Daniels.
Right.
He left glory.
[inaudible].
Here we go.
Darren till super aggressive here.
Now I wonder if a Wonderboy,
his knee is okay
because those,
uh,
he still hasn't landed anything now
except for those sidekicks to the knee.
Here's the land.
Anything to the head.
Nothing.
Wonderboy,
his knee seems fine.
He's moving fine tooth around so far.
No shot to the head.
Yeah.
Ooh,
kick to the body.
Well,
the whole thing with Wonderboy is just,
you make a mistake and he counters you
and so far till hasn't really made any
mistakes but wonder boys
found a few openings,
but there's never been like one big bum
rush where he'd left a gap and Wonderboy
could drop a ball on him.
Did I miss anything?
Nope.
Nothing.
But they did show the replay.
The knee buckling a Wonderboy.
It look pretty now.
Yeah.
From what?
From that sidekick.
Oh Wow.
From a side kick.
Front leg side kick to me.
But he's moving fine.
It doesn't seem like he's a limping at
all and he threw some kicks with that
left leg.
So you would be nice at one one.
It's hard to tell.
It's hard.
It would be nice if Wonderboy was
a little more aggressive though.
Yeah,
I wouldn't be getting knocked out.
K locked out you think so.
Same thing with the Woodley five
who was like go be more Christlike,
like and get fucking starched by Woodley.
That doesn't fighter.
He's a tower.
It's still,
you've got to,
well this is his style,
man.
This is his style.
His style is move around,
but the thing is till is so high level
as well that it's hard for this style to
even find its home.
You know,
you have an aggressive,
which counter striker this is,
I don't know what people expect.
Really.
Machida.
Yeah.
How about that?
My cheat at front kick
to vittores Cheetah.
How fucking dare you know.
Ooh,
the man's sign off fighting went,
you know what?
Enjoy the retirement.
Hey Josh.
Yeah,
crazy,
right?
That was one of the worst knockouts
effort and this just walks off fucking
nasty.
Starts praying.
Did you see the photo
of the foot on the face?
Yes.
Text book front kick balls
of the balls of the feet.
You think feature goes to ride?
Just juices with every
Brazilian drug ever?
Uh,
my,
my heart hope so too.
I pray for that at night.
I pray for Golden.
Like the master's division.
Yeah.
Just go off and want to see
veins in his teeth again.
It's crazy that he's still fighting.
Jesus Christ did.
He was around in the early days.
He's the only guy from
the early day still fight.
Oh yeah.
Caught them with that right hand,
man.
You could say the same
thing for Dan Henderson,
but he's officially
retired and he's retired.
But Wonderboy,
I mean [inaudible] was around a UFC 12.
That's crazy.
Henderson was around [inaudible] 98
so it wasn't much longer afterwards.
You know.
Crazy.
Really?
They fought,
right?
Dan Henderson Times v
Torn Kao them both times.
Yup.
Oh,
oh,
we caught all right Dan.
See till starting to get anxious here.
This one's gonna get in trouble,
man.
Ooh,
well he's looking for wonder.
Boy gets big.
Kaylin's it's using his legs,
man.
I mean his hands are dangerous,
but his powers in those fucking legs.
Oh Shit.
He's found that head kick a few times.
It was a sick slip,
but till who does till train with,
I don't know much about his
to come bone and Liverpool.
Uh,
his coaches calling,
I forget his last name.
It's crazy.
One of the boys,
dad cranes him,
right?
Yeah.
It'd be tough dynamic.
Ooh Damn that.
Not everyone has to touch.
Just touched him,
but he did touch them at the very end.
With that a round kick to the face.
You might be finding an opening for
that one to blitz out till just tag them
with that job.
I have a hard time believing
these judges don't have it.
Three nothing.
Right,
right.
In Liverpool dock to gun control.
Well not say dry judges are two.
Right.
Or the American judges and the
English judges are all morons though,
aren't they all around the world?
Unfortunately.
I love the fact that you could say
that you don't work for anybody.
I know.
Isn't it cool?
And you can't
have no,
oh no till.
Got poked in the eye.
Get the fuck outta here,
mark gutters.
We're worried about an
eye poked in anybody.
That boy,
that doctor got in that room quick,
but doctor just jumped in.
God,
what did he come from?
And now he's out.
He's trying to get a
little too much TV time.
Oh yeah.
Oh definitely.
And Marina don't mean to poke or Reno.
Oh,
they were booing him.
Yeah.
He's saying no,
no.
Boom.
Oh Shit.
Sometimes I poked really rev
a dude up or a Dick kick.
Oh my God.
Dan tells get wild here.
You know.
Don't get too comfortable.
Okay,
there you go.
Going over the top.
Oh shit man.
Talk,
fight.
Oh,
he's getting crazy here
dude.
That I poke.
Really poke him.
I wish you would have poked nine in
the first round or the round here.
Now I was trying to get loose
and I was about to get fun.
That was three.
So we've got two more to go.
Thank God this is a five rounder,
right?
Will be pissed.
Yeah.
It feel so.
I would not talk so much shit
on that fight is three rounds.
It ended there.
Yeah,
man.
That dude has a prominent forehead
cheekbone situation going on.
Yeah.
I think gang is kind.
Got a little bit of that.
A little bit of,
he's definitely got some
fucking ancient man and I'm,
he does.
I don't look like him.
He definitely boom.
That right hand.
That was the nice account counter.
I'm here.
Boom,
boom.
Oh,
that got him that night.
It did.
Definitely.
He slip with it.
Yeah.
He went with it,
but it caught him at
the end of it for sure.
Look,
not quite done.
I'm like tired.
This is his style,
you know,
and he's so efficient at doing that.
Oh,
both.
These guys can do this for 10 rounds.
Yeah.
Round four here we go.
God,
it's,
this is a fight.
That is a great argument for the
five round fight for high level.
500%
maybe we would feel so bad if we
were leaving here and then like,
who won?
Who cares what even happened?
Like what?
What are the stats on?
Oh Dude.
Enlist trenches and kicks.
Landed.
Yeah.
Unless you're super and
you'd be so does wonderful.
It was a hard jab.
Right.
Their kid,
they tilt better.
Watch his p's and q's though.
You are too hard man.
Yup.
But
juice is worth the squeeze
if can get knocked down.
Oh
Damn.
This is getting hot.
Yeah.
Cause Yeah.
And tills never been five rounds as he,
no,
I don't think so.
He hasn't switched in the EOC.
This first made it well first times
because his main event against cowboy,
I'll starch cowboys.
He hasn't.
Yeah.
This is the first main event.
Right.
And what about outside of the UFC?
How many fights he had?
What 17 or a 14 on crazy
speaks perfect Portuguese.
Oh,
does he?
I didn't know that.
Oh yeah man.
Fuck Darren till at damn,
this kid's marketable.
When he fought in Brazil,
uh,
he,
he spoke Portuguese to the crowd.
He lived there for like 10 years,
right?
Yeah.
I watched one of his,
uh,
older fights when we stop this guy and he,
spoke Portuguese to the crowd
after the fire looked the guy up,
10 fights were there.
Wow.
Yeah,
he went down.
It just went to live down there.
He had to get her to Liverpool because
I guess there's a little talk it for him
where he got stabbed.
Yeah.
Yes.
The,
yeah.
You can see the stem mark.
Where is it a lower like on his,
uh,
it'd be on his rights.
He got to Dab in Brazil,
but right above his hip in England,
in Liverpool,
in his hometown.
And his coach,
his coach told him,
Hey,
you gotta get Outta here man.
If you want to continue to have their
knives and the UK and often off,
how many more people
got to get stuff that's,
you know,
the London mayor actually said that
if you get caught with a knife,
it'd be prosecuted to the
fullest extent of the law.
What about if I got to open boxes,
princesses,
brother-in-law,
her brother got caught with one when he
went over there for the royal wedding
last week.
Oh,
that you got caught with a knife?
He took one because Trump said
that you should take one with him.
And he was in a bar.
Got,
oh,
he's crazy.
Is he crazy or brother's crazy?
She's a dime piece,
man.
I'm assuming you to Deb.
Nothing.
No,
I didn't get the fuck down.
I'm watching it.
It's fine.
Your son,
one boy with the step in Jab.
Not a lot of action that's fighting.
Oh,
Wonderboy looking for that left
hand over the top because it land.
Nope.
Just kind of grazed him.
It's Kinda hard to tell us back was to us.
It's can be a tough
fucking fight to judge,
man.
Tell us having a hard time hitting him,
that's for damn sure.
Beautiful Duck.
Under that,
we get this tail with a clinch.
What if he takes him down to,
we just stop the fight.
Interestingly,
the tills,
the one holding onto him here.
Oh,
elbow that clinches.
Mortised nasty.
Good elbow on the break there.
If you're one of my say
exactly what he wanted,
that light's kind of fucked up.
That lead leg it,
right?
Yeah.
Yup.
It does look a little bruised.
Oh Oo.
Good kick to the body.
I,
yeah.
You guys watched that show Cobra Kai?
No,
I haven't seen her.
I've heard the cost to be good.
Yeah.
No,
it's great.
That's a crazy well on Wonderboy.
His leg.
I really haven't noticed him
getting hit that much either.
It's on both legs to the,
obviously the right legs.
Worse with that left leg is pretty tender.
Roni till the ride
language really fucked us.
I don't really remember
him kicking that heart.
It must've been when he was
standing in southpaw sideways,
you know,
and now he hasn't gone back then.
Athey really not mine.
Let's just round it doesn't like it.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
He,
his footwork.
Just stupid.
So Darren till can't
really get a read on them.
But again,
the judges are given that the tail.
Yeah.
Nothing big has happened
where you go all that guide.
Definitely.
If someone,
if someone just knocked someone down,
you've got the fight and it shows Mike
LP got the good right hand to the body.
Such a high level chess game here,
which I dig it.
I'm on the edge of my seat.
But if you're just a regular fan,
like,
come on man.
I tell you what he's going to get more
shit is Wonderboy because there's one
Woodley fights.
Which thoughts?
It's fault.
It's not his fault.
I'm just saying the public thing.
Some shit I guess.
I don't know.
It's what it is.
It's this is the,
I mean you want to beat him.
You got to come after him
and you come after him.
You run into the woodchipper.
But the thing is he's not
winning when he does this,
but we didn't win against Woodley
when he did this for sure.
But he's obviously,
yeah,
he's obviously got
number one for a reason.
He's number one in the
world happened there.
Cut that back.
Leg is fucked up man.
Yeah,
I'll do friendly voice will.
he's wobbling a little on
the back to his corner.
That leg is fucked up man.
Maybe they just didn't loosen this fifth
round and just save it for the fifth
round.
Eddie.
I hope so.
Me Too.
Cause again,
if it stopped right
here I'd be bummed out.
I'm going to Sikeston pretty lack luster.
Yeah.
I was really trust to till
I'm 100% know that every,
every round of that gift to went that.
And then once it was like,
we don't want to like it too obviously,
and he gives one to one a boy,
I don't know.
I'd say he's up.
He's up three to one till.
Yeah.
Really?
Because of the judges.
Yes.
But knowledge is of what you think,
right?
Uh,
even then it'd be tough.
You can maybe go to two,
but I,
I'd say tills winning this fight.
I don't know about that.
I think Wonderboy is winning.
Can I get some goddamned copy?
Strike numbers,
Fox.
I know.
No wonder they left her ass.
Just kidding.
Can I get something?
How's your show going on showtime?
Enjoying it.
It's been good man.
It's been fun.
Nice to a lot of fun.
Did you know that guy that just died
without from the comedy division?
Yeah,
I did not.
Did you know,
everybody seems to think he's,
I might've met him,
but everybody seems to think
he's a really good guy.
That sucks man.
55 man.
I know.
Such a shame.
Crazy.
Burt loved the Gar.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I burned up some real nice to say,
but also the dice.
That's a bummer man.
Yeah.
Tills super aggressive
here coming off from you.
I'm sure he wants to get the finish
probably feels a little bit of pressure
and you should.
Okay.
They're saying Darren
tills corns very urgent,
like he's losing the fight.
No,
I think he's losing.
You do.
Yeah.
I think if I would count up all the
different strikes strikes that landed.
Yeah.
I think a lot of this,
according to the UFC thing,
I don't know,
hosted in terms of strikes.
Landed says 48 to 42 Gundam.
That's tough to judge.
Yeah.
That's impossible.
One aggressor,
right.
In Liverpool,
I got to crazy.
Five rounds,
48 strikes landed.
That is just not bananas.
A lot of defense going on.
Yeah.
A lot of missing is what I'm movement.
Which styles do you think
would make for a great,
oh,
this is a good writing sample and
tell a little jab to the grill face
sidekick,
please.
No one's really going balls
to the wall or they know
good
Darren to would go balls to the walls,
but wonderful.
It keeps moving.
It's hard.
Fucking writing keeps moving.
You don't get blasted in the face.
Yeah.
It's hard.
What did we come on man,
just sit there.
What was that about?
He threw a Shitty,
we'll kick and then shook his
head and then they touch gloves.
It's fun.
Fucking weird.
Oh,
switched up on them.
It's too or a little too
friendly for my liking.
He's looking to set up his
wheel kick with his left leg.
Someone throws something.
Anything.
The crowds like,
yeah,
that you have on there till,
but he doesn't,
oh there he landed a lefthand.
Why are they touching?
What do I to touch dab cause
got all the goddamn corner.
Oh is that about gorillas?
Don't act like that.
I don't understand this.
That does touch gloves.
Again,
too much respect.
I know there's not enough
killer instinct in this.
He's looking for that low fake and then
go with the high round kick off the
front leg.
He does that sometimes,
but he didn't do it and you just like
to know how many miles they've ran this
goddamn fight.
You kind of give it to them
for sticking to their phone.
No one's getting out of
composure here to pros.
Pros.
No,
I get the style.
You don't,
you don't want to risk it,
but if,
yeah,
if you're not balls deep into fighting,
you're not happy with this fight.
No,
I'm not thrilled with it.
This is like what I'm looking at it.
One of the most uneventful big events.
Who?
Good Jabs by till.
Oh Damn,
guillotine.
Okay.
Oh,
he,
I thought he,
Oh shit.
That's enough to win the fight.
100% that's all he needed.
Don't get drop time to go
a little bit of time to go.
Damn.
How hard does that motherfucker
hit and it didn't look like it.
Atlanta,
like behind the air.
We'd have to look at it in the replay,
but it look are you heard him?
I wonder.
Boy has got to move his ass now.
He lost the fight.
Well wonder boy,
he's in trouble now.
He's flat footed.
Yeah.
What are ways to be a little bit trouble?
It's what till lives where?
Okay.
Damn.
Wonderboy would went to
till just out of range for it to hurt.
This got interesting.
That's for sure.
Proud man.
Everyone's on their feet now,
but this is like wonder boy when
he fought Tyron Woodley to right,
got tagged,
got hurt and then people
rushing get dealt with.
Look at this Wonderboy
with a fucking take down.
Awesome.
No Shit.
Anything exciting when someone shoot
for a take down or these stills?
Yeah.
Oh,
straight left
Wonderboy still dangerous.
Crazy.
40 seconds.
Boys who tell just thinks
he has in the bag.
I don't think so.
I just think he doesn't want
to get tagged coming in.
He's a little tired too.
Mouth's open.
Hasn't been a high pace.
There's been a lot of foot work though,
so you might be a little,
well,
you got to rent.
Remember till did have a real hard time
cutting that weight and he's been going
through a lot.
You're right.
They need some get downs in it.
You Ain't,
you ain't lying.
No standups.
Just get down.
Get down.
Yeah.
There's no way can give one
a boy the flat after that.
It'd be hard pressed,
especially in Liverpool,
man until one of boys
in a tough spot though.
I don't know why he's
that happy about that.
That was um,
I mean he landed a good shot.
I guess he was trying,
it wasn't like he wasn't trying.
Yeah,
he was sort of unfolded.
Where would you rank till after that
lackluster performance cause he,
cause Wonderboy is number one.
You'll make him number one obviously.
I think you put them in the top.
Water is just a nightmare for everybody.
He's a nightmare for everybody.
Yeah.
Just it's tough to look good against him.
A win over him as a win.
You know he beat that number one.
Well he didn't even make
the weight so that's,
that's where it gets tricky because
no one gives a fuck about that.
Right,
but you're saying that they fought here.
Here's that front leg side
kick that wobbled his knee.
Good job.
Metro pcs.
A blocking the vision.
God Damn it.
Metro PC.
Why would they do that?
Why would they have that
right where you need to see,
I'll tell you right now,
if you're my friend,
you have metro pcs.
We are not friends anymore.
Knocked down,
knocked down.
Do you get angry with?
Just because of that?
Well,
no,
I get angry because the cricket of
wireless cell phones now cricket.
Oh Shit.
Hard fucking left hand.
Boom.
Right by.
That was legit.
He clobbered him right there.
Right behind the air.
Huh?
That was as legit as it gets done.
Most of that was the
legit shot of the phone,
like one legit shot.
That's why like if you have
49 other strikes at land,
do they even count?
I mean that.
That's a real,
strike that.
Do you ever use the word clobber when,
when you're calling fights?
I don't call fights.
Cooperates.
Claude was nine my addiction.
No cow bomber to old school collaborating.
Clobbered him clobbering collapses.
The thing says that,
right?
Yeah.
If the thing called tastic
for clobbering time guy,
I need to bring that up.
So what do we think here?
What do you think you think until all
hundred percent for one till around stone
close decision.
I think til split.
Someone's going to give
it to Wonderboy tills.
Some rebel,
some revenue wants to die in Liverpool.
I want to get going on Michelle.
They place that will they
set that place on fire?
If they do give to Wonderboy,
the report card and the paint,
you know there's some hooligans
then it's going to be a tough,
it's going to be a tough exit
strategy.
Is that a Dell,
Dell Bird?
Where the fuck her name is she
Adelaide birds fly her out there.
You never know.
See it everywhere fucker.
Does she go everywhere?
She like gives lessons
on judging and stuff.
You don't think they put
her in there for a reason?
You know,
cause she don't give a fuck.
So you can to do it on purpose.
I think they,
they want controversy.
Do you want people to get
used to fucked up decisions?
What we're used to it that's,
yeah,
yeah.
I think they,
they want that because if they
ever needed to pull something out,
like something was like,
dude,
this motherfucker has to win.
You know?
People are like,
oh it is Vegas.
Vegas,
Seattle boxing's crept as shit.
But with MMA I just think they
don't know what they're looking at.
They don't understand
they're not the west.
Correct.
They just don't know either way.
Oh,
here we go.
Here we go.
Jamie,
can you give us some volume
here we split up or be a killer
strip club Dj 46 and 49
boom.
Unanimous.
Oh,
you're
holy shit.
Wow.
Well he didn't even
need that knocked down.
That's a big fight for him.
What were some of those scores?
I can hear it.
(494) 074-0840 seven or
494649464847 well that's,
that's a big victory for him,
that's for sure.
He pointed Wonderboy.
These people they can up for you.
What does it feel like you're on your way?
Call it.
Hmm?
I think you said something bad.
I think you some potty language there.
What do you think?
I mean,
sorry,
strategic point.
Did you expect it to go the distance?
Did you think it was gonna
be like the whole winter?
I play games.
I don't speak it.
[inaudible] guys to flights up high on
the classified to have such
a specific way of talking.
I feel like it's so much cooler when
they talk like this is a fighter.
Yeah.
Well everybody,
that was pretty cool.
I bought book.
I'm going to show him that
be 40 so I was 13
can you hear me?
Shots in the morning.
Maybe it's the
not really.
Really?
I'd have to him yet.
Yeah.
Yes.
What is he saying?
What?
What are they saying?
Boy?
Fucking censorship.
Yeah.
Well,
let me,
let me hear the Bjorks neck.
Yeah.
Said everyone.
Anyone?
I don't care.
Yeah.
People asking me.
You might design the time.
She'll talk to me.
Okay.
God Damn
with the censorship.
Yeah.
Espn,
please let these guys swear.
Please.
Come on.
They're not going to let it.
No Way.
He's going to be worse and he owns ESPN.
That's true.
Good call.
They might not even let me
do commentary over there.
Have you guys seen Solo hockey about that?
You out doesn't,
he took over Star Wars,
right?
Yeah.
They be solo.
No,
dude,
I lasted literally six
minutes and I walked out.
Yes.
No,
six,
nine.
It's give it a shot.
No.
The reason,
the reason why I walked down,
I realize what it is about star
wars lovers in the chase scenes.
They,
they use the classic Star Wars,
Star Wars movies.
Music.
Yeah.
Like that music is just so,
Indiana Jones can't be corny.
Right.
I couldn't stand it,
man.
I couldn't.
I was the fucker and I was ready.
Dude.
I had fucking candy.
You see,
I was ready.
I had one of those of those
chicken baguettes with a barbecue.
Watermelon sauce.
Barbecue.
Watermelon sauce on you still walked.
As soon as I was done,
I killed it before then.
I was done with that before the movie
even started that the chicken watermelon
barge to go by myself.
You went to see
wow.
At The arc light in Sherman oaks.
Really?
You showed up for yourself?
My,
uh,
my wife took my son to some,
birthday party thing and they were
going to be gone for a couple of hours.
You might have said,
you know what I'm going to go to.
I like,
I like that the idea of going to movies,
it's just that they all suck.
But I like going,
I like,
I like buying some candy or solo though.
It doesn't matter.
I go by myself all the time.
I did.
I did not,
not so much since I had a kid,
but back in the day I would
go all the time by myself.
I think I've only been maybe three times,
not even in my life by myself.
I saw a these on robots only because I
want to be able to leave if I go with
someone else and I got a fucking state
cause nobody likes to talk to him.
And I like no.
Most people don't like leaving.
Most people they get,
so I got to fucking sit there
for the whole stupid movie.
So how I like minutes.
I liked it.
I liked the freedom to
leave cause I won't,
I want,
as soon as I don't give
a shit about the movie,
I'm out.
I or Deadpool two is amazing.
That was good.
I stayed for that.
I saw that by myself too.
That was good.
Yeah.
Deadpool to the school.
She moved by herself.
I don't know.
I really,
yeah,
I've never,
I I just need to,
I just need the freedom to leave.
That's really what that's about.
Hmm.
Dude.
That welterweight division
is pure fire right now.
Yeah,
no kidding.
Right.
Pure fucking fire.
I think at all the young
guys out of Colby Covington,
Uzman and then,
uh,
Darren till,
till if I had to bet on
one of them being like the,
the world champion be till you think so.
Yeah.
Out of all those,
the,
those three guys,
dangerous motherfucker,
that's for sure.
If you trade them with that guy,
I mean,
w the thing that wonder boy did that
was so interesting is he's just never
there.
He's just never there.
And it,
it made it a hard fight for,
to keep his composure
and fight five hard rounds and constantly
be chasing them and wonder boys never
there and wonder what
tagged him a couple times,
but til I was the one that
landed the big haymaker.
But you also see till under
control experience still stuck.
This technique is to be tough to beat man.
Now I'd like to see him against a
guy who has high level wrestling,
like a Colby come dinner Woodlea or uh,
even who you know,
who's been super high level restaurant
and you see that where it's not an ideal
match up for him.
See how he performs cause cowboy
and Wonderboy are there striker.
So it's [inaudible] wheelhouse.
Yup.
Let me see your Rda.
Bluesmen or Colby counted.
Yeah,
I would like to see him versus cope.
I think [inaudible] fine.
That's a good question.
Purple because a purple thing.
I'm pretty sure he's a purple.
He's been doing it for awhile.
Um,
but uh,
see I don't think you do Coby rich day.
I don't think you could kill
off the young lions yet.
I think you could let the young
lions go after the Robbie Lawler's,
the cowboys,
the RDAs.
We'll do it that way.
Did they think that way or do they just
try and make the best fights that can do
UFC?
There's no,
oh just what do you like?
You know,
I think it's just whatever the fuck works.
Cause this fight doesn't make
too much sense for wonder boy.
Right.
But as a fun fight for us to watch.
Yeah,
very fun.
Fight to watch,
man.
There's a clubbing punch.
Boom.
Yeah,
a lot of power.
Yeah.
He's got a power and he's a big fella.
I mean if he,
if they wanted him to have to weigh
188 they know that he's probably,
well,
well north of that I'd
probably come in and,
well,
north of 200 c but missing the weight.
We don't make a big enough deal of it.
I don't give a F.
I don't really care either.
But it is a problem in,
it's a huge problem.
It's such an advantage.
But like with Mackenzie dern,
after she missed it,
I didn't care.
I'm like,
all right,
do your thing girl.
And she missed it by seven fucking pounds.
Man,
that's so big.
That means it doesn't drain her.
So when she goes,
that's a huge advantage.
She goes to fight.
She's not drained out huge.
That Mackenzie dern fight.
Holy Shit.
That was like some UFC two type shit.
She took that check down mountain.
Her soccer.
No,
she knows that.
It was like that.
It was like a hoist versus uh,
that uh,
that Dutch kickboxer with the
g pants when she got a crap.
But her striking was the impressive
thing cause she landed a bunch over hand.
She does that.
She has big,
she's not afraid to throw
down Mackenzie fan man.
She's got giant balls.
Her ground game is so high.
She will scrape through that.
It looked like that chick never trained.
She looked,
she looked too thick though that fight.
She didn't like it.
I like thick but then
there's like damn girl,
you need a,
we need a little pride here.
She said to her the way she's dressed,
if she was in a miniskirt
with a halter top,
don't get a twist and I'm on board,
whatever just went,
I'm just saying that like the love
handles are spilling over the top.
Like all right now it gets
a little thick sometimes.
I like that.
I'm not mad at it but
it just looks better.
It's all depends on how much
ask goes with the package.
You're right.
The front,
the front to back ratio.
It depends.
See this,
why,
this is why we can't be
on ESPN or Fox fire me.
Good.
Yeah.
Well it's not even saying they just
make me just do the paper views.
I'm fine with that.
That's all you do,
you know?
Oh wait,
no,
I do the previous to the prelims.
Uh,
well I want to have Latino cause well I
guess it would just the contract comes
over like does everyone
like the UFC tonight?
Crew.
Everyone's everyone like,
just check this over.
You have seen,
I was never working for Fox.
I didn't do the fire.
It was one of my,
one of these days.
But one of the stipulations
of my newer contract,
I said I don't want to do
the Fox events anymore.
And that deals through when you
don't have to say it's already done.
It's already done.
I mean it was a bit like this year.
I don't do any of the Fox events.
If you notice,
like when there are big
fights on [inaudible].
I know you don't do,
don't do any of them.
I'm not even done the big ones.
Nope.
None of them.
Zero paper.
If he's still doing it right.
Do you want to do anymore?
Too much work?
Um,
did this suit is not a big deal because
they have the suit there for me,
but the,
my issue was a fox actually
paid me less money,
less money to do the whole fence on Fox.
But I was like,
you guys are never paying you.
Yeah,
I thought the UFC Pagan,
no,
I get to fuck event.
It's a Fox event.
So,
um,
that,
but it was also,
I didn't like when I first
started doing it for them,
they got in my ear like the
very first events for Fox.
They were like telling me what to do.
They were like telling me
to take it down a notch.
Don't be so amped up about that.
Yay.
And I was like,
what?
What are we doing here?
I go,
listen,
I do commentary.
This is what I do.
I've been doing it forever.
This is how I do it.
If you think you can change me,
then we're not going to work together.
I'm like,
what a real problem.
And that was a faux deduction,
right Joe?
Yes.
It was a fox junior.
Dos Santos,
Cain Velasquez.
That was,
yeah,
I believe that was the first one.
Yeah,
but it's just,
I just didn't,
I didn't like it.
They want a sports guy like,
look,
MMA is what it is.
It's,
it's fighting.
It is a very specific kind of sport
and I've been doing it the way I do it
forever.
If you don't like the way I do it,
that's fine.
Don't hire me,
but don't try to get me
to become some sports guy.
I'm not interested in that at all.
When I commentated for pride,
they told me,
I said,
Nice.
Too much.
No.
Say Nice was like,
no.
Couldn't even speak English.
I think.
Nice shot.
Nice Jab.
To their credit,
they stopped.
They stopped doing it
after the first event.
When I voiced my displeasure,
I just let them know like
really clearly this isn't,
we're not going to do in this.
I'm not going to change how
I do it to make you do this.
It's not even that.
It's just like,
if you don't like the way I do it,
this is not an option for you to direct
me and tell me to do it the way you like
it because you think that that's better.
This is a personal choice by one or two,
whoever the fuck the people were
that were producers or executives,
I don't agree with them and
I'm not doing it that way.
Like this is just how it,
it's like real simple.
Like if you bought a Ferrari and
it had a certain sound to it,
you're like,
man,
I don't like this sound.
Can you guys go back to the
factory and fix these mufflers?
They'd be like,
what
do you high like this
is what a Ferrari is.
You don't like it then
you're like Ferrari's,
no,
no.
I like it for right,
but I want it to sound like
a Corolla doesn't work.
They'd be like,
no,
you probably a bad analogy,
but the idea behind it,
you get,
I'm not,
this is what I do.
Like I get amped up if
some shit is going down,
these guys were throwing
blows and I'm screaming.
It's because I feel that way.
Some would call it passion.
Yeah,
it's bullets.
Legitimate Passion.
I'm not,
I'm not faking it,
but they didn't want that.
It did.
But they let it go after awhile.
But it's not like they fought
for me when I quit either.
How long has the Reebok deal for?
Uh,
three years.
I think three years.
Two to three years.
I wonder if it worked out for Reebok,
like his Reebok.
Reebok exploding now because of this.
Well,
Adidas zones Reeboks or
Adidas is killing it,
but I dunno,
free bucks exploding.
They,
they're the niche,
right?
The MMA,
the with crossfit.
So they're in that world
and to Reebok's defense,
you know,
they,
they made the offer.
They don't know.
They didn't know what the deal was.
They know they are screwing over fighters.
It's more of a UFC thing.
It was not Reebok Reebok,
it's like,
Whoa,
what the fuck.
It seemed like even the UFC wasn't
aware of how much fight is for actually
making off of sponsorships.
I mean you and I know that there was
some debate as to whether or not,
I mean they just,
they had a distorted perception of how
much some fighters were making and they
just think they kid,
I think they talked to maybe
the top 10 guys and like,
Hey,
we're going to pay this.
We would take care of you in this way.
And then the rest of the
guys get on board and they,
you know,
but,
but again,
I get it man,
if I'm dating,
I'm not making decisions based
off those 10 to 15 top guys.
I'll make my,
my,
my decisions that's going to affect my
bottom line and one which is what they
did.
One judge and the pain fight gave every
round and Jason Knight One judge did
look at it like you,
like he was on his back and he didn't get
taken down but he was the one that was
aggressive on the ground.
I agree with that.
I don't think you just take it one step
down and have one thing you do and then
be in control.
It's just been edited.
Yeah.
I to get out of here soon.
Boy Sets.
Wrap her up.
Uh,
Eddie Bravo.
Tell everybody you're a tinfoil
hat comedy at Cobb's Friday,
this Friday at cobb's in San Francisco,
Saturday in Sacramento,
the punchline sacrament.
And then I'm at the ice cream
at the ice house on the 15th.
This June 15th of the Ice House.
One show only.
And then I'm in Houston,
Houston Improv,
uh,
the 22nd 23rd,
June 22nd 23rd.
You can get your tickets@livenation.com.
[inaudible] DOT com.
All right,
we love you guys.
Bye.
Awesome.